[Musique]
ces versions classiques c'est soir
bon
les dieux sampler d'avant riz haricots
des gouttes
est ce que tu pourrais te manier le cul
[Musique]
non
c'est super oui on les frères ont fait
l'émission well et c'est mieux
[Musique]
m
oh
c'est leur ami soeurs ennemies bienvenue
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
émissions ou avec nous ce soir
le livre qui fait scandale
la femme de will lui raconte tout pareil
pour réguler
il ya la prochaine star féminine
une porte
la sueur
ryan utilise un quinze de bons clients
l'apocalypse du capital
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
le bligh tech de 18 est sacré
mais inégale
non ma fille
[Applaudissements]
oh
bonsoir à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'ai rien à dire
j'ai marqué baffie ans bahia red alert
c'est blanc il n'arrête pas de faire des
blagues des plus à trine dernière ouais
heilomed là ils m'ont mis en veille
villars les gens tu vois il s'en ait ont
fait croire que l'air le village georges
bien déconner mes amis toi pourquoi pas
de la villa ne peut pas là un mot dalida
la tête du client ça c'est une arme non
j'ai pas vu qu'il y avait je découvre
les fiches parce que je n'étais pas là
n'a pas travaillé 6 mai sur autre chose
[Musique]
ouais bravo il est arrivé à temps je
vérifie un truc est maintenant
antisociales
ça
social
guillaume depardieu
[Musique]
voilà
ça se passait mieux que la dernière fois
que tu es venu là pour marché non
j'arrive à escalader un petit peu
commence à prendre l'habitude
ouais alors guillaume depardieu acteur
de cinéma tous les matins du monde cible
émouvante dans les apprentis césar du
meilleur espoir pola x mart peau d'ange
aime ton père donc régulièrement à
l'affiché au cinéma mais aussi souvent
guillaume depardieu à la une des médias
prison ferme pour revendre d'héroïne en
1993 accident de moto en 1995 amputation
de la jambe en 2003 puis altercation à
trouville avec un pistolet à grenaille
neuf mois avec sursis 5000 euros
d'amendé
voilà donc vous êtes un garçon à la fois
qu'on retrouve sur les ailes blanches
des films et une est à la une des médias
et c'est pas fini puisque vous publié
chez plon un livre d'entretiens réalisés
avec marc olivier fogiel sont amis
depuis qu'il est le dimanche soir c'est
plus mon ami quand un jour après et puis
tout va bien tu vas te réconcilier avec
lui et sur ce plateau très volontiers
voilà donc un livre qui va faire grand
bruit et qui s'appelle tout donné
d
alors guillaume depuis la publication
des bonnes feuilles de ce livre dans
paris match tout le monde en parle c'est
le cas de le dire
et d'ailleurs la première mise en place
chez les libraires a été mercredi
dernier de 80 mille exemplaires alors au
départ c'est muriel bel air qui est
éditeur chez plon qui lie un portrait de
vous dans l qui vous appelle et qui vous
dit une vraie histoire racontée et vous
lui dites vous tombez bien j'ai envie
d'écrire
donc voilà donc muriel bel air pour
accoucher de ce témoignage
contact marc olivier fogiel avec qu'ils
étaient amis depuis 1997
et donc c'est marco qui vous a accouché
alors au niveau de la méthode de travail
avant de passer au contenu du livre lui
dis tous les jours entre septembre et
décembre 2003 j'étais chez guillaume à
bougival tête bêche sur son lit avec un
magnéto en marche pendant trois heures
par jour ne le mettez vous dans le même
dans le même journal vous dites qu'en
fait vous avez enregistré huit
entretiens avec les sais c'est quoi
alors il ya eu 80 retrait entretien
d'une heure en fait
et puis non mais ça ça doit être le
journaliste qui a dû laisser tromper par
la vérité c'est ça si vous avez un
entretien d'une heure avec la tête bêche
sur le lit du rif bien alors on va y
aller un sont montés de bêche
oui
alors le livre commence à votre
naissance vous dites je ne suis pas les
normales ma mère a pris un médicament le
distilbène qui a été ensuite interdit à
cause de ses effets secondaires il 300
cas de jeunes filles qui sont nés
stérile et vous vous avez eu des
malformations corporelle dites vous des
eaux en plus des trucs comme ça va des
hommes plus un cerveau en moi c'est
bizarre et où des eaux en plus beau brun
et on les a enlevées ces autres n'ont
jamais non non parce que c'était pas
sauf si je me cassais sur l'artère
fémorale
non mais c'était pas c'est pas grave et
le sexe l'opération du sexe ça c'est
plus marquant quand même se trouve à la
puberté quand ça commence à bien frais
tier 1
déjà tout petit vous vous sentez
différent des autres voilà c'est ça
somme toute sa place dans appelle moi
confiance je sais c'est mon métier mais
il a passionné quoi il a vibré
il a vibré ok ça y est on continue c'est
chiant avec simple donc tout petit déjà
vous vous sentez très différent des
autres
ce mouvement marque finalement de 7 c
ouais opérations non puis tu te
retrouves à l'hôpital gilou tu rates les
cours puisque tf1 est coachée par humain
voilà alors vous parlez aussi de vos
rapports avec votre père vous dites les
rapports avec mon père sont pas normaux
non plus il travaillait tout le temps je
le voyais jamais il n'était pas
compatissant de ce que vous viviez à
l'école sert qu'à l'école on vous
emmerdez à cause des valseuses à cause
d'un certain nombre de films que votre
père avait fait est en fait jamais il
vous a dit c'est pas grave
laisse tomber guillaume c'est des
connards ils n'étaient pas compatissant
non mais c'est même pas sale d'être
compatissant ou pas c'était je sais pas
moi j'avais pas
vous savez pas comment réagir vis à vis
de ça donc généralement bon ça donnait
des soucis quand je me battais tout le
temps vous dites mon père il m'a eu trop
tôt on sait que 108 x 10 watts et dès
qu'elle veut mais je confirme
ouais gérard depardieu on peut s'il veut
pas trop vous aider parce qu'il n'est
pas beaucoup et à l'école non plus donc
oui mais c'est touchant ouais et alors
vers 13-14 ans vous commencez à pu rien
[ __ ] pour commencer à fumer du shit à
sniffer de la colle donc c'est quand
même assez jeune vous nous trouvez vous
dit j'étais devenu quasiment autistes
ouais parce que je n'aimais pas du tout
le le monde qui m'entoure
c'est un peu ennuyeux ennuyeux donc nous
sommes réfugiés surtout dans la musique
vous écoutiez quoi de tout beaucoup de
points restent à l'époque c'était dans
le hip hop et les lui vous preniez le
dernier train pour paris vous allez à
paris vous marcher dans les rues pendant
toute la nuit le matin vous preniez le
premier train pour rentrer à bougival
faisait quoi la nuit je déambulais un
peu dans pareil quand je prenais je
m'inventais des identités j'avais les
barges été soit fils de notaire soit
fils de
deux militaires soient des trucs
bizarres enfin des trucs comme ça mais
chaque fois j'avais le privilège de
l'anonymat donc c'est comme ça en fait
que je me suis d'abord j'ai compris que
l'on pouvait avec un peu de persuasion
les embobiner tout le monde c'est assez
intéressant et puis ça m'a permis de
découvrir plein d'univers différents
vous disiez jamais que vous étiez le
fils du jardin parce que jamais
maintenant sinon c'est très drôle à 16
ans vous décidez comme ça un jour sur un
coup de tête de devenir mercenaires de
partir en afrique larmes au point pour
contrôler les ressources pétrolières et
minières et [ __ ] l'occident dans la
merde ça c'était une grande idée que
vous aviez way j'étais vraiment prêt à
partir mais bien sûr bien sûr on sait
que c'est une petite barbe de trotskisme
c'est pour le faire la révolution
mondiale non c'est pour ces pour un film
ça c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vénal ça c'était une semaine dix autres
mercenaires et puis la semaine d'après
vous écoutez le requiem de mozart vous
fondeur l'armée vous dit c'est ça que je
veux être c'est mozart
ouais c'est un peu le résumé comme ça ça
fait un peu mais c'est ça c'est ça
non en fait je voulais vraiment me
barrer pour quelque chose qui valait le
coup est finalement bon j'ai eu la
chance de l'écouter mozart ouais parce
que sinon je me bats et ça vous a retenu
ici
non c'est même une certaine manière ça
va donner
un sens au fait que le choix ici en
occident ceci dit on peut on peut
arriver aux mêmes choses le but mais en
construisant et pas en détruisant voilà
alors à l'époque vous êtes un d'argent
viennent pas d'argent votre père non non
vous êtes gigolo je veux essayer le
grand course il a maintenant jt c'est
pas pour pas que pour l'argent c'est par
exemple l'ouverture et aussi bien sûr
vous êtes gigolo pour pour femmes pour
hommes
vous commencez avec des femmes mûres
j'aimais bien les fameux mur est donc là
ce n'était pas tellement pénible non non
c'était plutôt s il ya un squeeze
c'était rigolo de luxe quoi maintenant
j'avais le choix je sais les clients
ouais ouais c'est toujours plus agréable
avec des mecs aussi sérieux vous
raconter le premier mec
le premier ouais 14 ans ouais mais s'est
pas passé grand-chose la première fois
euh non non juste préliminaire ouais et
après c'était plus sérieux c'est arrivé
ouais vous avez appris quoi dans cette
expérience
ben jamais tourné le dos j'ai signifié
des douches
non j'ai appris mais j'ai appris plein
de choses j'ai appris que c'était dans
la tête aussi les choses ça s'était très
liés heureusement quand vous vous
retrouvez en tour de la première fois il
ya un caïd qui vous protège et vous
échapper aux sévices sexuels habituel
des prisons ou enfin aussi vie sexuelle
non je pense pas que que j'étais une
proie
ainsi vos la non j'ai échappé surtout au
lynchage
ouais pendant la première fois que
j'allais en taule c'est pas encore pour
usage de stupéfiants sont pour braquage
de weston et de rester l'époque jacques
baudou nous ça va encore ouais enfin bon
et puis quand est-ce qu'on m'aide et
wesson avec une doudoune
je n'ai pas la forme d'un gouffre de
gouverner dans divers 18 ans vous
commencé à mettre le nez dans la poudre
c'est la durée six ans vite j'ai perdu
six ans de ma vie là dedans
ouais mais je le pense ne nous a rien
apporté du tout si mais ça m'a apporté
justement de mais rétrospectivement
parce que je m'en suis sorti mais parce
que je suis costaud quand même non mais
moi j'en connais tous mes potes de
l'époque sont s'en sont pas sortis ils
sont soit devenu fou soit ils sont morts
soit ils ont fait aujourd'hui un jour
ensemble
cela en fait le mec qui vous a branché
dans la drogue dans la poudre dans
l'héroïne c'est notre prof de solfège
ouais de contrepoint d'harmonie vous
recueillez un jour chez vous parce que
son père était mort
et un jour vous le voyez en train de se
faire un fixe dans la salle de bain et
vous essayez quoi ouais enfin j'avais
ici un petit peu avant je faisais un
remplacement
je vais avoir 16 ans quand j'ai essayé
mais c'était juste un trait d'héroïne un
hasard quand même jamais rien fait alors
là évidemment quand on prend de
l'héroïne au début c'est vachement bien
on croit que tous les problèmes sont
réglés même c'est après comme on est
toujours au début on en prend pour être
bien puis après peut pas être humain
rythme en attaque après on court après
alors vous essayez tout voir ici non
seulement l'héroïne mais aussi l'héroïne
mélanger que la cocaïne ce qu'on appelle
le speedball le speedball ensuite vous
avez pris du crack
vous n'aviez pas peur de vomi quel
cerveau non non mais j'ai lu quelque
part qu'on utilisait on utilisait toute
façon juste un dixième de nos neurones
ont toute une existence fois - et donc
mon nom mais je n'avais pas une approche
très quantitative des choses c'était
plutôt c'est plutôt fallait tout essayer
ouais et puis un jour en revenant de
hollande ou par départir pour le ski
quand le fameux prof de solfège qui vous
a initiés vous appelle il vous dit je
suis mal je suis mal viennent des panais
mais j'étais parti pour décrocher un don
qui vous appelle je suis mal viens viens
viens
bien mais des flammes avait pas des
choses bien dépanner c'était un truc bon
que je comptais pour pas être prendre
pour pat mal le prendre le lendemain
matin
ouais et toulon j'ai eut passé et puis
là j'ai vu le flag est vraiment comme ça
je la sens en plus vous faites serré
vous finissez donc évidemment en prison
alors en prison vous dites kapaya pas de
broc évidemment n'ya pas d'héroïne mais
il ya la fiole c'est quoi la fiole mais
c'est ce qu'on donne dans toutes nos
toutes les prisons en france c'est une
donne ça pour les mecs parce qu'ils sont
il ya beaucoup de toxico quand même les
vols avec violences ou les vols quels
qu'ils soient enfin de la rapine tout ça
c'est vraiment l'essentiel des gens qui
en prison à 70 % c'est lié au manque et
à la drogue
donc on leur donne pour les calmer pour
pas qu'ils hurlent toute la nuit comme
en ce moment qu'on leur donne des
tranquillisants des opiacés des enfants
les shoots quoi on avait prévu oui mais
un jour ouais un jour ou deux puis après
toute façon moi j'étais mariée quand
même que je voulais m'arrêter là ça
tombait bien les jardins de façon à vous
prévenir que vous dites ça rappelle
balladur pour essayer de vous faire
sortir de là en fait vous lui en voulez
parce qu'il trouvait que ces quand même
trop facile d'être le fils de jr de nom
mais c'est moi je ne sais pas du tout
comme ça j'ai jamais été comme ça et je
serai jamais comme ça non j'ai été
condamné j'estime injustement
ils en voulaient c'est un exemple tu
crois c'était un changement de politique
tu vois c'était un peu la droite qui y
vivent mais il fallait bien montrer que
attention maintenant les jeunes ça
rigole plus on est donc bien là
maintenant on continue à dérouler le
même tapis quoi donc c'est assez
intéressant de voir que ça ne sert
strictement à rien et qui met pas les
gens qui sont malades en prison se
trouve ça ridicule
vous avez voulu à votre père d'avoir
essayé d'intervenir auprès de nouvelles
à bazire est pas la dire vous auriez
préféré finalement qu'il voulait cela
pour empêcher référé que qu'ils soient
pas là du tout qu'ils ne viennent pas en
plus me discréditer
moi j'ai dire je voulais faire ma peine
jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas de problème
là dessus
moi je fais ma peine c'est même si
j'estime que j'ai j'ai rien à [ __ ]
là-dedans justement c'est motivant c'est
très motivant
vous vouliez vous c'était une certaine
rédemption par là par la punition non
pas du tout olala dieu m'en garde nous
avoir ce genre de pensée la gynéco
chrétienne non merci non non non c'est
plutôt devoir de mettre les choses à
plat avec l'esprit clair et de voir dans
quelle société j'évolue et donc à partir
de là c'est très bien je sais que je
suis malade je sais maintenant que on
prend les manettes comme ça qu'on en
fait ça je c'est vrai ça va avoir les
idées claires et arrêté six ans plus
tard vous êtes arrêté comment tout seul
sans rien on sort méthadone comme ça
ouais solide dure voilà et puis ensuite
vous raconter dans le bouquin votre
amputation suite à cette maladie
nosocomiale
on vous propose soit d'avoir la jambe
raide toute votre vie soit vous faire
amputer ça fait un bon petit parallèle
du vin les mecs qui sont malades dont
les fonds ont tous les mecs qui n'ont à
les autorisons putois
j'ai testé pour vous ouais vous avez
préféré à être amputé plutôt que voilà
j'aimerais tout ça vient c'est
infaisable intenable et en faisant jouer
plus rien faire non mais il y en a même
qui m'ont dit quand même entité bien les
verts les sept pas fait comme tout le
monde mais il y en a qui arrivent à dire
ça les yeux dans les yeux en pensant
vraiment que c'est vrai que j'ai fait
exprès pour faire bien dans le
curriculum alors votre père vous appelle
donc après cette amputation ils vous
appellent à l'hôpital il vous dit ça va
comment vous dites ça va très bien
espèce de sarcasmes ça va très bien j'ai
fait un drôle de rêve papa j'étais
entouré de six toute nue qui me sucer le
moignon oui j'ai vu tous leurs voisins
il avait des limites au sens de l'humour
vite mon père je l'aimais je le déteste
pour les mêmes raisons son impuissance
non mais c'est toujours pareil de façon
les gens les aiment
quand on les aime vraiment si vous lisez
aussi pour leurs défauts il n'a pas été
assez dur avec vous pensez franchement
ouais non je n'en mets c'est une manière
nous quitte autrement plus dur aussi de
dire à quelqu'un va te démerdes toi tu
vas voir à la dure quoi moi je trouve
que ça m'a amené vers une liberté qui
est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai ce doigt
le concéder je trouve que c'est
intéressant de dire à quelqu'un
démerde-toi toute façon tu vas être bien
être obligé un jour te démerder donc
mais c'était peut-être un peu tôt est-ce
que vous lui en voulez de ne pas vous
avoir donné un exemple parce que vous
dites dans le bouquin mon père s'est
fait ce que je dis ne faites pas ce que
je fais ouais vous trouvez qu'il manque
d'intégrité et d'éthique c'est à dire
que vous pensez que finalement non mais
quand on quand on a des trucs à soi faut
le cacher vraiment quoi il faut pas que
ça se voit le centre sur les ferries qui
soient plus discrets pour vous donner un
exemple plus plus droit bah oui je suis
pas ton café un prêt de ne pas venir en
se posant représentant garant de la
justice quelle qu'elle soit après mois
après ce que j'ai vu tu vois si c'est
pas le top crédibilité ouais je vais
découvrir oui comme tous les gens de sa
génération vous découvrez kiseka mais
qu'il a fait par tous voila comme moi
non mais ça c'est bien après ouais moi
j'étais déjà barré depuis longtemps
j'étais déjà
mais ma tête c'était vous avez dix ans
j'étais déjà dans mon univers on est
plus m'approcher quoi découvrez même
qu'il a une fille avec karine syllabes
demi soeur il n'a pas osé vous en parlez
vous la prenez la prison de sa naissance
parce que karine silla appelez votre
père devant vous ouais pour dire que
tout s'était bien passé nous apprenait
sa vie privée par la presse en fait
ouais mais aujourd'hui aussi la manière
dont vous l'avez appris en disant par
ailleurs j'ai fait un peu a franchi vain
puisque maintenant je sais voir un peu
les rapports
ouais je trouve ça bien moi je trouve ça
bien qu'ils soient avec cette femme là
ouais ouais
préférez les fanny ardant carole bouquet
j'ai rien dit alors parler de votre mère
aussi elisabeth depardieu vous dites
qu'ils sont en instance de divorce
depuis 14 ans parce qu'il veut pas
lâcher sur le plan pognon qu'on ouais
mais le problème il est milliardaire
votre permis franchement c'est assez
opaque
ouais je vois pas ce que vous dites
quand j'étais petit me donnez pas
d'argent ma mère il veut pas divorcer
parce qu'il veut pas lâcher non mais
qu'on justice car si fier c'était
beaucoup d'argent principes d'éducation
de ma main et je trouve ça très bien
d'ailleurs
c'est à dire que moi je n'avais pas plus
d'argent que mon meilleur ami est bon
comme c'est une famille nombreuse quatre
enfants ces milieux bon ouais pauvres
donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien mais
non mais mon père il n'est pas du tout
pas généreux c'est pas vrai il faut pas
qu'on croit ça non plus et c'est
quelqu'un qui a du mal à filer une pièce
par contre peu de feeling brics le way
bon moi j'ai pas j'ai pas tendance à
demander facilement une brique vous
avait divorcé c'était réglé avec élise
n'avait pas attendu 14 ans quoi ouais on
est on est en train de faire ouais
heureusement que j'avais louise quand
même non oui alors quand votre père a lu
le bouquin il nous a dit que certains
passages étaient pas bien qu'ils étaient
un an mais parce qu'il n'avait pas lu
je connais comme on y lit c'est comme
quand il dit je lis les scénarios il
avait fuité trois trucs
si vous un dialogue intéressant et le
prend s'il voit un truc et après le lit
mais bon là il avait juste parcouru
trois feuillets il a dit oui au fond si
stigma plein juste pour me dire qu'il
trouvait ça un pudique
ouais et vous lui avez dit que vous le
trouviez indécent ouais il la lui
maintenant je pense nous est pas une
nouvelle non ils vous répondront dans
gala vous l'avez lu ah bah oui j'ai eu
des nouvelles par exemple c'est terrible
ce qu'il dit parce qu en fait il dit si
ça l'aide décrire ce bouquin tant mieux
pour lui si elle vous attendez comme
attitude vous voyez attendre quelque
chose de violent
franchement je m'en fous ça me m'empêche
pas de dormir c'est pas ça qui me fait
lever le matin
ouais maintenant vous avez fait ce
bouquin vous sentez libéré de quelque
chose - je sens en tout cas on ne posera
plus les mêmes questions à chaque fois
que je viendrais faire la promo pour un
truc que j'ai fait que j'estime très
bien et qui mérite plus largement de la
tension plutôt que sur ma famille ou
quoi que ce soit comme ça j'ai fait
aussi pour ça que j'ai trouvé bien mon
intérêt là dedans comme face à coucher
avec ma famille laguë dans les ronces et
je trouve ça infernal c'est terrible ça
va les gens vont se lasser attention
gérard sa dernière fois vous en parler
là alors oui c'est à dire marquer le
coup quand même la dernière fois c'est
énorme ce groupe
après vous avez pas être vos films oui
je vais les faire sur tout
j
[Musique]
serais-tu est pire nous aurions pu être
le fils d'alain delon non non non ça va
comme ça ça va comme ça ça me suffit
c'est pas mal
[Musique]
montrouge eux
alors guillaume vous avez vidéo vous
avez eu des barbes faire l'interview à
peine dame
[Musique]
ce que vous préférez chez vous la
qualité de mes silences
c'est que vous haïssez chez vous la
qualité de mes silences au cinéma ce que
vous préférez
au cinéma les gens mais en contre ce que
vous haïssez au cinéma mais con way les
plus grands moments de votre vie ouais
je suis originale la naissance de ma
fille de pierre le pire la naissance de
tempère je sais pas encore ce qui vous
plaît le plus dans la vie
après l'amour ce qui me plaît le moins
attendre l'avant votre plus gros coup de
fric c'est un truc que j'ai pas fait
justement c'est mais c'était pour faire
monter les enchères pour voir jusqu'où
ils pouvaient aller le plus grosse perte
c'est ça s'il l'a pas fait votre plus
belle histoire d'amour guillaume laurent
baffie ya un soufflage bas va plus belle
histoire d'amour c'est à ma fille est la
plus minable la plus minable le jour
j'ai failli tomber un mois noir
ouais qu'est celui de plus sexy en vous
je sais pas et de moi un sexy quand je
suis bourré ouais ce que vous préférez
dans le sexe moi j'aime tout ce que vous
détestez dans le sexe les interdits
donner c'est d'oublier ses tours
c'est bon vous répondait à des questions
comme s'il était une question de
quelqu'un d'autre avec beaucoup de
détachement beaucoup de distance
j'ai un peu mis derrière quand même tout
ça ça fait un bon ça fait six mois
maintenant je suis passé à autre chose
parce qu'on a pas dit c'est dommage
c'est que même s'ils se parlent par
presse interposée il termine toujours en
disant que l'un aime bien l'autre donc
finalement tout va bien quoi c'est mon
côté positif je voulais et maintenant
on partait sur les chemins à bicyclette
le
iad et fernand y avait affirmé il ya des
francis et sébastien
voici sylvester
non
[Musique]
et
bonsoir
maddie da silva montant s'était pas
monsieur ballon il est mort
ah bon bah oui sylvie vous de bonsoir
monsieur alors avec vous on ne change
pas de sujet on va rester dans la drogue
drogue a accepté par la société puisque
c'est celle que prennent les coureurs
cyclistes
alors vous êtes la femme de villy route
soigneur de l'équipe festina arrêté en
1998 ce qui a déclenché la plus grosse
affaire de l'histoire et on l'avait
reçue ici votre votre mari willy pour
son deuxième livre qui s'appelait sexe
mensonges et petit vélo lundi
tout est dit alors récemment à
l'occasion de la sphère cofidis des
femmes de du coureur ou des femmes de
soigneur en tous les cas des femmes de
doper ont pris la parole pour raconter
leur vie brisée et dénoncer la loi du
milieu il ya ellis gaumont il ya le
ratio ti et vous sylvie veux tu
alors vous dites six ans après festina
rien n'a changé en fait ou plutôt si
maintenance et des transfusions
sanguines des produits vétérinaires mais
en fait c'est toujours la même chose
qu'à l'époque de l' affaire festina
mais en résumé on va dire ça n'a pas
servi de leçon en gros ça servi
strictement à rien le problème il est là
et ce qui se passe c'est que chez
festina par la force des choses il avait
essayé de
d'un petit peu contrôlées par des
médecins par le directeur sportif
histoire d'éviter de faire n'importe
quoi ce qui veut pas dire que c'était
bien je dis pas ça mais qu'est ce qu'on
se retrouve s'il en a pris puisque qu
est-ce qu on se retrouve avec des
transfusions de des autotransfusions des
produits vétérinaires dans des camions
dans des camping-cars qui suivent la
caravane de toutes les courses sans
suivi médical
s'en suivit vous dites sarkozy va mettre
des flics dans les écoles pourquoi il
aurait pas des flics qui fait les
contrôles antidopage je dis que
simplement et sarkozy mais des flics
dans les écoles ça imbsheim un petit peu
la population et c'est normal parce que
je trouve c'est complètement nul mais
bon fermons la parenthèse
quand les flics ont fait des descentes
ou sur une tour de france ou sur le tour
d'italie ça fait un drame il ya quand
même grève des coureurs tout le monde
s'est arrêté parce que c'est dramatique
jeudi de toute façon ils vivent dans une
sphère est dans un milieu qui est à part
donc ils sont dans leur monde
il s'auto contrôler c'est comme si vous
aviez un directeur de société qui a la
foi qui à la fois senica liste voilà cc
je veux dire c'est comme les hommes
politiques et surtout en gros en grotte
en gros comment il va willy besoin je la
verrais bien vous envoie le bon jour
fait là bas j'avais déjà tu te souviens
souvenez vous de ces lenteurs du bordel
c'est pas démérité c'est pas un menteur
je dénonce ce qui donne un brevet soit
déposée quelques arrêts pendant le
procès mais les impôts après avec les on
n'a pas dormi pendant trois semaines ils
ont plus de drogue
non je suis en arrêter et entre temps
mais qu'est ce qui fait la vie quoi
sérieusement nice et travaille dans une
société transports voilà et vous vous
trouvez toujours la fonction publique
sur thierry vous êtes tous les impôts
n'ont posé aucun dommage
pourquoi je travaille dans une
collectivité territoriale
cette voie là alors justement quand vous
avez rencontré willy veux tu en 1983 bon
vous travaillez déjà dans la fonction
publique à l'époque les pharmaciens
liquide des soigneurs et alors le soir
comme ça à l'époque c'était assez cool
vous dites vous en parliez sur un coin
de table
parler du dopage comme vous auriez
parler d'autre chose s'il avait été
maçon ou boulanger quoi c'est tellement
c'était assez normal mais ça prenait pas
des proportions fait doucement avec les
maçons non mais c'est vrai à l'époque
c'était pas un drame
c'était pas du tout un drame est que ça
restait vraiment demandé dans des
proportions va dire fait normal jeune
homme déraisonnable déjà mais non mais
c'était pas un souci parce que ça reste
et ça reste et ça vous fait pas la vie
comme ça bouffe et après quoi
vous avez déjà quand même le p ô les
hormones de croissance les chrétiens les
membres corticaux anabolisants donc à la
fin des années 80 les pratiques étaient
assez limitées discrète raisonnable
ouais ensuite fin 80 début 90 c'est
arrivé avec le cyclisme italien avait
des coureurs italiens lteo voilà les
italiens
quand on lit le p o et de l'avant c'est
vrai que ça complètement dégénéré et le
tournant ça a été en 95 96
là ça commençait à devenir à venir très
chaud parce que c'était plus des soins
des préparations mais c'est carrément de
la drogue ce qui se passe vous parlez
vous parlez comme le milieu thierry
attention avant soit une préparation
soit en préparation c'est le mot qui ne
parlait pas de dopage
voilà on parlait pas à faire je ne
parlais pas de dopage ou de l'accès de
l'extérieur par les ménages
et là ça commençait très chaud dont 95
96 7 les mecs sont devenus accros
à leur truc c'est arrivé c'est vrai avec
toute une génération de coureurs
italiens hollandais
d'ailleurs il ya eu des décès ça a été
quand même dramatique
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi appris blonde
je suppose que bruno roussel à essayer
d'encadrer ça
c'était c'était à la limite beaucoup
plus intelligente que de laisser faire
ce la distribution de potion magique
mais embellie qui n'ont pas cette fois
ci le pot belge et des amphétamines la
caféine de l'héroïne de la cocaïne quoi
vous dis pas ça avant de faire les
courses parce que ça c'était détectable
contrôle antidopage
ils prenaient ça à l'entraînement et
après il y avait le côté complètement
festives ou naissants soirée pour le
reste estime willy ce qui est incroyable
c'est qu'en fait ils prenaient du pot
belge pour pour l'entraînement mais ils
on prenait aussi pour faire des soirées
ils en prenaient pour faire les frais
dits sûrs qu'ils étaient drogués en fait
voilà un mois et la chebba d'enquêté non
c'était cet entraînement s'est vu de
l'extérieur de l'extérieur on disait ça
mais non c'était quelque chose qui était
pas si c'est le mans qui bannit cessé
dans leur langage le dopage et le dopage
la dope et la broque ce soit en
préparation
on va vous envoyer une fois qu'ils en
prennent pour faire des fêtes et vous
vous alliez à des fêtes de coire
cyclistes et puis vous étiez un peu
largué vous avez monsieur pas comme les
autres
vous avez essayé d'en prendre oui deux
fois piqûre dans l'épaule ouais et alors
ça vous a fait quoi
el hafed aux yeux
vous êtes resté éveillé toute la nuit
ouais jusqu'à 10 heures ouais ouais mais
la totale
ce à quoi la puissante avec moi à
l'époque oui alors le comble c'est après
c'est la période 95 98 alors là ça
commence sérieusement à bouffer votre
vie de famille vous dites dans le bac à
légumes du frigo plus de produits
dopants que d'autres choses enfouies pu
mettre en orbite à un proto feu de place
oui je dise le frigo était à moitié mon
mari c'est ce qu'ils voulaient c'est
quoi le budget comme dans une équipe et
les buts g km
il faut demander au courant parce que
c'est eux qui paient ça avec leurs
primes est ce qu'ils gagnaient au noir
sont censés directeur de course et
directeur dès maintenant il s'en sortait
pas bien parce que je veux dire c'est
ils ont obligé personne
moi j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un que
j'aimais vue alors là donc vous vous
refusez finalement que les gens viennent
se servir chez vous en voulez pas ce qui
fait que votre mari will il est obligé
de remplir son coffre et de faire le
tour d'europe pour suivre les cours et
pour les prestations mitigées des son
métier glaciaire aussi qu'est ce qui
faisait où il est vous deux pour tenir
là pour tenir le coup bas ils en
prenaient aussi comme les autres que ça
veut dire que le soigneur en prenait
d'attendre les soigneurs en première
année la femme du soutien elle a pris
deux fois l accord soit mort et les
parents prennent voilà baby
principalement quand même et à ce moment
là vous dites ça devient complètement
obsessionnelle les piqûres avant la
course
vous dites j'entendais plus parler de
sport quoi c'était ça on n'entendait
plus parler de sport on entendait parler
de soi une préparation normale de
croissance de paix ou de contrôler deux
voilà on attendait plus du tout parler
de sport c'était devenu secondaire
d'ailleurs si vous regardez une caravane
du club
une caravane du tour de france vous avez
à peu près 5000 ses mille personnes pour
200 coureurs elles sont les terres
maintenant ouais on croit et c'est là en
1998 donc être la sphère festina bruno
roussel le patron de l'équipe festina
vous appelle il vous dit brûle les
carnets dis à ton mari qui prennent tout
sur lui on va tout payer
on va recouvrer on va s'arranger comme
ça parce que moi j'ai appris mon mari
est en prison par un coup de téléphone
de la police judiciaire en me disant à
votre mari il va bien je vais vous le
passez deux minutes vous posez aucune
question
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
lendemain en fait ce qu'ils ont aimé rvc
que donc on vous demande vous dit voilà
il va tout prendre mais c'est pas grave
on va payer
et le lendemain vous voyez le départ de
l'étape et là ils sont tous contents
comme si de rien n'était de rien n'était
je commence par entendre une roue celle
qui dit je comprends pas qu est ce qui
se passe parce que mon équipe est au
complet et il me manque personne et
les coureurs qu entre autres à l'époque
qui dit moi je connais à peine j'ai pas
qu'est ce que c'est si tragique pour les
autres jouent pas au courant je me suis
pas ici parce que j'ai dit mais
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui me raconte
pas ce que moi je n'ai vu pendouiller
avec sa perf
je veux dire dans les chambres d'hôtel
c'était ça m'énerve quand vous décidez
vous dit
chacun joue dans le sens caen l'étonnant
moi je suis moi eux c'est eux
et voilà on va pas tout prendre sans
rien dire non j'ai dit moi j'ai rappelé
bruno roussel en irlande et j'ai dit
c'est bon je compris tout de suite il
fallait pas jouer ce jeu parce qu'il
était mort donc au lieu de brûler les
carnets de les cacher je lisais cachez
vous savez ou chez une amie paysanne
voilà dans les tables des vaches voilà
alors parce qu'on écoute maintenant tout
le temps que tout le monde le juge tout
le monde perd parce que moi j'ai eu
droit la perquisition à la maison c'est
la totale le freeroll est évident et le
frigo était vide parce que quand il est
parti pour le tour j'ai dit je veux
strictement plus rien la maison du pont
toute ta merde et tu la gère les routes
c'était comme ça
malgré ça vous avez gardé de l'amour
pour willy lagarde et de l'amour pour
vous malgré ça votre pays n'ont même pas
son fiancé riels pour lui demander ça
ouais bah vous voyez bien quand même
ouais ça va toujours ça va voilà enfin
en tous les cas à l'instruction vous
produirez ses fameux carnets que vous
aviez sauver de sauver du feu n'allez
pas vous êtes menacé vous recevez
beaucoup de coups de fil
ni le soir gagnon arrivants anonyme de
qui je me rappelle pas c'est embêtant
c'est des graines courageux toujours des
coups lui qui forme ça j'étais toujours
et voilà en fait votre mari a parlé aux
procès mais ça aurait changé quoi ça
arrive apparemment ça rien changé la
seule chose c'est que maintenant on ne
peut plus dire qu'il a fait ils ne
peuvent plus dire qu'ils savent pas
comment ça se passe qu'est ce qu'ils
risquent je pense que c'est vrai à
l'époque personne savait ce qu'ils
risquaient parce que quand il se faisait
attraper
il ya eu six fois où ils se sont quand
même fait attraper ou à une fronde fait
attraper faits vérifiés alors il s'en
sortait on donna une casquette un
cuissard et maillot quoi j'ai alors tout
est tellement dédicacer une photo et ça
roulait cette fois sa part où les sap a
roulé ce qui me scandalise le plus c'est
que les personnes qui parlent sont
bannis du milieu c'est ça si ce qui est
arrivé à vous et à votre mari mais c'est
moi personnellement je m'en fous je
serai monde demande
cc on est venu demander mon témoignage
je le dis volontiers je dis la vérité je
trouve que c'est complètement nul 2-2
rien dire alors tout le monde dit on
veut faire avancer les choses et
personne ne parle
faut que ça soit encore une fois les
femmes qui parlaient de toute façon le
problème il est là au lieu de ben ils
sont une poignée à avoir parlé et au
lieu de les bannir je veux dire de les
mettre complètement de côté c'est les
gros méchants qui ont fait exploser la
bulle prend l'expérience des gens qui
savent le problème des contrôles
antidopage c'est qu'ils ont une
génération de coureurs de retard ils ont
dix ans le pays est arrivé fin 80 début
90 premiers contrôles de le paix au 1er
janvier 98 voilà donc 8 en 8 9 10 ans
voilà une génération
donc c'est en gros ce qui est en train
de se mettre dans les fesses
actuellement ce sera ça sortira dans dix
ans quoi ils trouveront les contrôles
dans dix ans qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
rien la mas blanc maintenant tout de
suite des choses que je dis mais qu'est
ce que ben écoutez écoutez les gens qui
savent comment ça fonctionne
qu'on leur dise comment ça fonctionne et
peut-être pourquoi pas une coming out 1
c'est la mode cobra ou des sportifs ça
commence un petit peu qu'il fasse il
faut sauver ou les routes non
le sauver longs rallyes va très bien tu
penses quoi de tout ça c'est insensé
quand même toi tu te fais ces récifs et
poutres en taule pour exactement les
mêmes trucs et qui sait bien qu'après
les mecs qui font le tour de france je
n'ai pas gagné d'étape
ouais mais la preuve que ça sert à rien
de toute façon la preuve c'est que chez
festina
il y avait dopage qui était organisée
depuis trois quatre cinq ans exactement
que je sais plus et ils se sentent
jamais fait choper un contrôle ils se
sont fait jamais ils se sont fait chaud
c'est mon mari qui se fait c'est ce qui
s'est fait choper à la barre il
actuellement les mecs qui sportives qui
se font attraper sait plus s'il est plus
tout coup lyon du peloton chez festina
et les contrôles inopinés étaient au
courant le jour et l'heure auxquelles
elle avoir lieu dans ma copine inopinés
donc conclusion des courses
le tout c'était de pas se faire choper
avec plus de 50% de taux d'hématocrite
dans le sang hop on avise avait une
petite machine par laquelle il
contrôlait le saint il y avait 52 53
perfusion d'eau qu'on faisait descendre
le taux s'était finie très compliqué
voilà pourquoi c'est le disent pas les
mecs qui viennent parler
vous savez tous à vos jeux c'est des
trucs pas peut-être me flinguer en
sortant mais non alors tous les cas
merci d'avoir témoigné merci
et
et maintenant en
m
voici greg le millionnaire américain
[Musique]
bonsoir comment sa maman chérie
les breaks pourquoi prend 10 minutes
pour lire le bouquin honnêteté
intellectuelle avant que ça commence
bien
comment valou très bien très très bien
et comment va bébé très bien et bel où
il va bien bb c'est le surnom bbc ont le
surnom de marica 1 c'est ça voilà et
loup c'est votre surnom alors grégory
basso vous avez été l'été dernier sur
tf1
greg le millionnaire le héros de
l'émission de télé réalité qui a battu
tous les scores d'audience durant deux
mois est nommé truelle d'or
sa règle d'or c'est mieux alors le
principe de l'émission c'est un faux
millionnaire dont qui invite 20 fille
dans sa villa de rêve à ibiza pour
choisir la femme de sa vie
ce qu'elles ne savent pas c'est que cet
homme n'est pas millionnaire mais masson
et c'est vous donc maïka que que greg a
choisi en fait le seul vrai
millionnaires dans toute cette affaire
sérieusement c'est gérard louvin non
chef lui demandé j'ai pas vu l'état de
son compte jusqu'à présent serait
identique
je lui souhaite ouais c'est une émission
de télé greg le millionnaire
institutions c'est interdit la télé en
prison oui c'est ça oui c'est un mec qui
agresse devant lui qui choisira une
bonne l'aguiché puisqu'on a découvert ce
soir c'est que le fils de depardieu bon
voilà le tour de france je te raconte
pas et tf1 la télévision voilà où ça en
est les gens sont déçus alors page 57
incroyable qu'un grec qui veut lire
voici un passage bien bon phase aller
greg le millionnaire salies imaginez
qu'on vous ait proposé de faire grève le
polytechnicien est un peu plus difficile
oui et règlent à coups de boules ça
c'est vrai
17h20 et c'est vrai qu'on fait maïka
crois que vous êtes un millionnaire
pauvres je sais pas qui c'est tendance
non mais pendant l'émission jeux je m'en
fichais tous est cet argent cette maison
cette voiture sortir la poubelle
vous l'avez vu tout de suite que c'était
pas un vrai millionnaire non-jeu gvg pas
j ai pas prêté vraiment attention en
fait j'ai découvert cette personne comme
comme une autre comme ça ouais alors ce
qui est génial avec vous dans cette
histoire c'est bien entendu vous étiez
de mèche avec tf1 tôt pour mentir aux
filles pour leur faire croire que vous
étiez millionnaire risque est encore
plus drôle si vous avez menti à tf1
c'est la magie ça extraordinaire c'est
dire qu'il y avait un mensonge dans le
mensonge
vous leur avez vu leur avait fait croire
que vous étiez masson et vous avez
oublié de leur expliquer que vous aviez
fait de la taule quoi oui
[Musique]
évidemment ça fait un scandale parce
qu'il pouvait pas appeler l'émission
greg craig le dealer lui même et lui
sionnel vous avez pensé au parloir mais
bon et puis après ils ont découvert vous
aviez fait des films pornos sur greg
leurs ardeurs enfin de ceux ci n'ait
jamais eu de film porno une équipe de
charme
ouais on va en parler troisième sujet
polémique la fameuse marjolaine qu'on a
retrouvée morte
troisième problème donc la fameuse
marjolaine la candidate asiatique tu te
souviens pas de marjolaine ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils sont soumis oui oui
non mais j'ai vu des zappings des trucs
utiles ils disaient ferme ta gueule qui
fout la merde et offert la marjolaine
qui a déclaré que j'étais homosexuel
je pense qu'il est mieux placé que
quiconque pour savoir que c'est pas le
cas
attention là parce que vous avez dit que
je retourne à marjolaine c'est pas très
bien non puisque vous avez dit qu'il
s'était rien passé je dis que j'avais
rien c'est ouais
ce sont des appels facturés mais c'est
quand même intéressant du palio ouais
non mais c'est une gentille fille
alors greg grégory basso pour rétablir
la vérité pour établir votre vérité vous
avez décidé d'écrire un livre
autobiographique aux éditions robert
laffont qui s'appelle ma véritable
histoire voilà greg le millionnaire sera
quand watts alors ça commence évidemment
sur le mensonge et sur le flip qui
s'ensuit vous êtes sur le point de
partir à ibiza pour retrouver ses vingt
jeunes filles dans cette sublime villa
de rêve ne vous n'êtes pas heureux dit
pas heureux car vous n'avez pas fourni à
tf1 votre casier judiciaire où figurent
les 50 tall auquel vous avez été
condamné pour trafic de drogue
décidément c'est ce qui me fait rire
c'est de voir cette société complètement
levé rôle est en fait le nom mais je
pense que ça arrive à pas mal de monde
je crois qu'il ya pas mal de monde aussi
dans les su puiser qui c'est arrivé vos
premiers démêlés avec la justice
remontent à la classe de terminale
grégory c'est ce que vous racontez dans
votre livre
quand gantés cagoulés vous conduisait un
camion plein d'ordinateurs volés et vous
faites attraper
parce que vous êtes dans une station
service et vous payez avec un chèque
volé là vous aviez piquer les
ordinateurs c'est ça j'ai une langue
j'ai une longue période où j'étais très
con way je serais pas allé en prison je
crois et si ce ne serait pas déjà douze
mois
heureusement ça finit bien
vous avez 12 mois avec sursis quand même
ça c'est que j'ai passé mon bac y que
j'étais plutôt bonne et un bon élève à
ce moment là ils m'ont ils ont été assez
gentil je pense à 12 mois avec sursis
peut-être qu'ils auraient peut-être
qu'ils auraient dû être un peu plus dur
maintenant avec du recul ça marche c'est
ce que j'essaie de dire tout à l'heure à
guillaume c'est à dire que je n'allume
si son père avait été un petit peu plus
dur avec lui peut-être qu'il va fait
moins de conneries dans une claque dans
la gueule non
guillaume il récupère alors ensuite vous
découvrez les rêves pis l'ecstasy et
vous consommez jusqu'à 25 extra en un
week-end c'est beaucoup quand même nom
de france
c'est là j'étais plus trop plus trop -
mais j'étais plutôt capable d'aller
jusqu'à ce qu'il faut de moyens ouais
c'était pas le joli sexta qui est aussi
les hassidim aussi la coke enfin j'ai
bien chargé un moment en vain un moment
vous en prenez trop fait un mauvais trip
vous êtes prêt de l'acide en présence
d'un chat et le chat devient fou quoi
non ça c'est moi ah oui c'est toi ce
qu'avance de lire des livres drôles
guerre si tu veux lire des livres de
drogués sétois nous c'est qu'elle veut
on peut et va lui lieu
j'ai pas devenu fou mais il a décidé à
un moment non il est décidé à moi il
s'est dit faut que j'arrête d'en prendre
faut que j'en vendent
non non c'est pas venu comme ça en fait
c'est venu à partir du moment où j'ai
commencé à vouloir payer meadows
c'est un engrenage en fait dans lequel
tu t'enfermes et qui serait plus qu'ils
seraient plus parce que t'es pas ce
qu'était pas tape à la force et à pala
tafalla chez pas en tout cas la volonté
de tout arrêter t'as pas la volonté de
redevenir simple parce que tu es de
réseau le monde un monde à part en forêt
et les gens autour de toi sont normaux
et de critiquer essaye de te faire
comprendre d'être d'être montré que tu
deviens fou et tu te rends pas compte
tu t'en rends pas compte parce que tu es
dans un autre monde et voilà alors bien
sûr la belle vie quand même parce que tu
emmené dans une boîte c'est +3 versé une
bouteille quand vous partez en vacances
c'est dans les îles donc effectivement
vous avez la bonne vie et la belgique
avec du recul maintenant je me dis c'est
andy powell
c'est je pensais à ce moment là c'était
la belle vie mais je vois ce que j'ai
fait autour de moi pas fini chez louvain
a pensé pas
bien bien en tous les cas à l'époque
l'idée que vous pouviez tuer des gens
avec la drogue que vous leur vandier ça
vous a pas effleuré
j'étais pas je n'ai pas acheté
inconscient du pid voilà et puis un jour
tout bascule vous recevez un coup de fil
du chef dealer le patron du réseau
depuis la gendarmerie de valréas en
espagne et il vous dit viens te rendre à
voir là dedans je suis séropositif
monfils a le sida
je suis dans la mouise je suis dans la
mouise viennent dire que j'ai rien à
voir là dedans je viens de te rendre
et puis voilà quoi et de la gendarmerie
ça m'a fait plaisir ça m'a fait plaisir
sur le coup vous imaginez puis pendant
deux mois je reste en cavale j'ai fait
une [ __ ] en l'air plusieurs fois j'ai
vu mes parents qui étaient très
malheureux ce moment là ouais
pour la première fois j'ai vu mon père
avec les larmes aux yeux puis j'ai
décidé de rentrer de leur nez vous êtes
rendu oui là vous comprenez que l'idée
c'est de vous faire porter le chapeau
et tout le monde l'aimé porter tout
frais tout le monde balance tout le
monde et vous ramassez quand même la
plus grosse peine cinq ans ça calme
ouais on pourrait aussi penser que si
vous avez pris la plus grosse peine
c'est parce que vous étiez le plus
coupable ne pourrait on peut dire ça de
manière c'est ce que je disais moi
personnellement on juge donc quelque
part quelque part je pouvais pas me
défendre mon avocat pourrait pas
vraiment me défendre non plus parce que
je me mettais dans la gueule du loup
j'étais con quand même à la faire ses
10000 ecsta 85 kg de cannabis et 300
grammes de cocaïne je ne sais pas rien
qu'en fait ils ont regroupé deux
affaires trois affaires le cannabis on
n'avait rien à voir là dedans y avoir de
stade dans lequel on n'avait rien à voir
non plus mais bon il représente quoi de
trois jours de consommation passe
donc là vous vous retrouver en taule
greg vous en profiter quand même pour
faire un moment une gamine qui passe une
dénommée sandrine qui vient me voir au
parloir pendant un quart d'heure walf
une gamine qui passe c'était une fille
que j'aime à vouloir le gardien se
retourne pendant un quart d'heure est
appelée donne la fiole mais vous lui
faites un mot non c'était de
l'insémination artificielle un sérieux
oui j'ai pas si on peut vraiment appeler
ce qu'on a fait à ce moment là dans le
parloir faire l'amour pas se faire
l'amour cm de plus tendre que ça je
pense mais bon on a fait ce qu'on a fait
de pauvres ça fait mouche
joli prénom mojawi cv ça faisait 14 à 14
mois et c il y avait la pression donc
cet enfant vous l'avez pas garder l'a
pas volé et on a bien fait et à la
sortie de prison vous n'êtes pas les
cinq ans parce que avec les remises de
peine ou en fait quand même beaucoup
moins fait deux ans et demi c'est sage
en sortie au conditionnel ouais c'est ça
et la sortie vous dites pour quelqu'un
comme moi l'incarcération a été une
bonne chose
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que si
j'avais pas été incarcérés si je mettais
pas fait arrêter chez pourri je serais
aujourd'hui d'être ce qu'ils n'ont
peut-être en prison pour plus pour plus
peut-être dans les bas-fonds de je ne
sais quoi et ça m'a fait du bien quand
je suis sain je me défonce plus je suis
plus sain que les trois quarts des gens
que je connais maintenant ma drogue
c'est le sport comme c'était à l'époque
le vélo et
plus tard nous encore avec le système
plus rebelle moi je pense qu'on peut
rien faire contre le système de toute
façon en france c'est parle pour toi tu
peux a vendu mon âme au diable encore
pas encore fait je pense pas peut-être
que ces gîtes à louvain si tu nous
entends le dicton quand l'on voit un
intérêt qu'on s'entende prison vous
devenez stripteaseur soit saisi du strip
j'ai fait des clips de charme
les clips érotique on a beau ne s'est
jamais faite pour ne sais pas mais bon
jeu ce n'était pas désagréable entre
nous soit dit a tourné à s'était pas
métier si désagréable que ça ça vous
dégoûte un peu vous devez tarzan chez
disney ouais mais ça ça fait rire les
gens gentils parce qu'on a tous fait des
métiers de merde on est obligé de tous
les boulots que j'ai fait jusqu'à
présent c'était sur une scène c'est
celui qui sait celui dans lequel je me
suis le plus éclaté et laissa pas me
griller dans la vie il faut revoir c'est
d'enlever dans la parade vous pouvez
vous croisez pardon
il s'explique il a fait camille mowgli
c'est marrant légende c'est par le jeu
ça c'est des fratries oui c'est argent
et jay z et géniteur qui les acrobates
et voilà alors c'est à cette époque donc
que vous tourner un film porno alors
vous dites dans le livre que c'est un
kit de charme érotique
oui alors discuté mon chéri parce que
c'était un clip de charles problème
c'est que c'est sorti en vidéo votre
toit éclats vous pouvez rien avec marc
montrer mot la gelée vue oui oui là-bas
alors vous avez une mon sexe quelque
part oui j'avais vu une pénétration non
alors est ce qu'on peut appeler ça du
port nous non reconnaissait le clip de
charme
quid de charme c'est dans ton coin adam
beats et les deux armes voilà c'est le
porno et le hard
un porno donné raison
tokyo fait du mal est-ce que vous avez
attaqué dans ceux qui ont ressorti ce
clip de charme comme vous dites non
parce que parce que parce que je n'ai
pas les 1 par contre je vais attaquer
les journaux qui ont dit qu'ils avaient
fait du porno est d'accord moi je ne dis
pas que j'avais fait du porno enfin
voilà donc pour connaître après la
prison ces petits boulots tout ça même
si tarzan c'était sympa vous êtes un peu
déprimé à présent c'était de la
rétention de charme que c'est un peu
déprimé comme le vélo c'est ma
préparation physique c'est ce qu'on vise
le nom tous les cas quand le casting de
tf1 arrive vous croyez plus haut rien
vous dit la tour infernale vous pensé
partir à l'étranger
un à las vegas comme ces petits êtres
les gars soyez en fait ils aiment faire
des couilles en or ce qui pose c'est
quel tiens voilà je suis resté parce que
sinon ça aurait pas été drôle cette
émission du loup voilà alors
heureusement une fois vous êtes enfermé
dans cette dans cette ville agisse a en
compagnie de ces charmantes jeunes
filles tombées sur marie cas ici
présentes à la première fois que vous la
voyez vous dites waouh
ah bon c'est pas la france bloquée
vous dites elle rayonnait - croire aussi
celle payée mais oui c'est la seule à
exister auprès des autres ce qui s'est
passé c'est quand il ya eu la première
la première rencontre c'est vrai que
c'est la première que j'ai remarqué
parce que parce que j'adore les filles
brune aux yeux clairs au terme at voilà
hélas une assez belle silhouette de l'om
et je pense bien d'un tatouage sur le
pied c'est très beau et le piercing vous
pouvez pas imaginer où ça roule entre
les demandes et non comme c'est son père
qui fait des piercings j'espère qu'il
n'a pas fait un endroit où je pense
marica rassurez moi c'est plutôt le
nombril c'est papa qui fait les celui
qui a fait le tatouage aussi voilà donc
en vous la voyez vous dit tout de suite
s'est-elle quoi ça arrive ça me fait
toujours un ça le fait toujours fureur
jamais un mot pour vos euros elle
n'était pas d'une amie pour critiquer
les autres films ni pour eux ni pour eux
ni pour me brancher d'ailleurs parce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'elle allait mettre
en râteau la fin soit elle avait compris
tout de suite vous étiez pas vraiment
millionnaire j'ai sur le coeur pudique
et super discrète c'est un petit peu le
cas en fait sur soi l'étranger pas mal
de filles apparemment qui avait
découvert à cause de quoi ils ont vu que
vous étiez pas un vrai millionnaire
c'est ma grande gueule je suppose
l'accent peut-être non l'accent à rennes
avant tu peux être millionnaire et du
sud non c'est que j'ai
j'ai une grande gueule il faut le dire
et je suis impulsif et
et j'ai la tête je crois je me lâche je
suis assez naturellement plus qu'un
millionnaire
tu les entendent pas souvent comme ça on
fait ça c'est ce que les filles me
disais après moi je pensait bien tenir
mon rôle j'ai essayé en tout cas puis
j'ai laissé des indices un petit peu
aussi tout au long de l'émission parce
que ça me faisait ça me faisait flipper
bras les indices de justes il s'adonne
manque et tout ça en parlant de la
maison alors là j'étais avec elle en a
discuté alors quand il fallait surtout
pas lui dire ça mais si j'ai fait c'est
ça c'est pas finot de glisser disons que
j'ai eu envie de me pendre à tous le
lendemain j'avais un peu peur de sa
réaction donc en fait oui à moudre aux
aviez peur qu'elle loue vous à ce jour
elle découvre métier pas un vrai
millionnaire était persuadé c'est pas
moi qui l'ait choisie c'est elle qui va
choisir la paix est en fait vous vous
étiez assez contente d'apprendre qu'ils
étaient pas vraiment millionnaire pas ce
que vous dites je savais pas très bien
comment on vit avec un millionnaire à
ces charmantes ça ouais je crois que je
serai pas à l'aise avec avec un mec est
plein tube ouais les repas où il faut
pas bouger
le golf tout ça ça m'intéresse pas les
séjours les autres c'est épouvantable un
nom n'ira pas jusque là qu'un bon alors
marica vous n'avez pas été choqué par le
passé de grégory quand vous avez appris
le clip de charme comme idi stripteaseur
gogo danseur la tôle les ex tu as tout
ça non pourquoi j'ai pas déjà jugé un
père qui est un score depuis 26 ans donc
les mecs qu'on fait de la taule
j'en ai déjà à croiser bah oui de ses
amis bon bah voilà le répète avec des
taux la ruine et nous dire là oui il ya
des gens qui se suicident chez eux
ouais mon père connaît pas mal de gens
qu'on fait de la taule la plupart de ses
amis menacé ça dure voilà vous étiez en
famille quoi et pour moi les gens qu'on
fait de la présence pas forcément des
gens qui sont mauvais maintenant les
gens qui sont intelligents et qu'ils ont
acquis ont pris une leçon de ça pour moi
c'est
c'est des gens qui sont bien tout le
monde a droit à l'erreur et puis il a
payé sa dette
merci à l'époque j'aimais beaucoup
sandrine aussi quand même erreur le
montage était assez justement assez
sympa est-ce que vous avez envisagé de
vivre à trois avec sandrine on apprenait
on n'a qu'à prendre un chien n'aboie
cendres et oui vous l'aimez pas à 100
mais n'a pas du tout voir et marc
javelle noël mais un différend falloir
vous croyez aux signes america vous vous
dites
greg est sorti de prison le 2 mai 2000
et il m'a offert ma bague le 2 mai 2003
vous pensez que ça c'est un signe
important c'est pas forcément à 6
initialement je me sentais pas un signe
du ciel cesser
ouais donc l'incidence de coïncidences
aussi c'est qu'ils et à revendre en cas
disney et que votre père son surnom
c'est un fait ça pour vous c'est
important ça veut dire que c'est très
important
ainsi votre tatouage présent que j'ai
déjà des spirales et sur l'anneau qui
vous a offert les spirales aussi pour
vous c'est un signe ça non c'est pas
assez pâques c'est ainsi je pense c'est
qu'il ya plein de trucs qui ont il ya
des petites choses je suis sûr qu'avec
avec des amis vous avez des points
communs ou bien on a toujours envie de
partager des choses je trouvais ça sympa
qui les fait argent que mon père son nom
d'artiste soit argent c'est pas des
signes qui évoque pour vous une
prédestination être ensemble toute votre
vie quand même à la ville est tellement
long que je peux pas vous dire si je
vais rester toute ma vie avec lui
d'accord maïka je vais mourir demain
c'est pas trop tard tu comprends plus
alors évident quoi aujourd'hui greg le
millionnaire mais aujourd'hui il est
toujours intermittents du spectacle il
ya une prime d'exclus que gérard louvin
diverses
excusez-moi 1250 euros par mois ça fait
combien on ecstasy marqué pour un maçon
ont travaillé pour bruit que c'est pour
oui c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est le comble
racing signe oui
mais oui su qu'on sait un signe le fait
qu'il soit masson et qui bosse pour
bouygues mais c'est vrai bien sûr j'ai
pas fait gaffe il ya plein de signes en
fait finalement un peu qu'on voulait
mais bien votre livre
j'aime bien le versailles est déjà gelée
pas déjà gelé qu'une crise ne rien dire
que je l'écris avec les avec quelques
années en collaboration avec catherine
siguret qui a qui pour moi
extraordinaire qui a réussi à me faire
sortir des choses que j'avais pas
forcément envie de sortir
là je dis ça parce que marjolaine
excusez moi de revenir à marjolaine mais
l'a dit
physiquement il me plaît vivre avec lui
c'est une autre histoire
à moins de lui greffer une cervelle
franchement non mais sans chichis ça me
touche pas voilà je suis d'accord on
veut pas du tout voilà ça peut pas
toucher à la vingeanne excuses ouais
vous trouvez ça c'est un bac l ai dit ça
vaut c'est différent vous le préférez
dans la vraie vie ou dans la villa ibisa
à la vraie vie qu'est-ce qu'il est
différent tout c'est quelqu'un de vrai
c'est quelqu'un de bien et à ibiza elle
était pas vrai dans la vraie vie
continue à vous faire des cadeaux oui
oui oui
pourquoi par exemple une belle montre
refusons des fois des commandes et
fleurs il est fidèle
je sais pas magnéto serge vous savez pas
pourtant les femmes elles le centre ça
quand même mais elle me fait pas trop
confiance elle a pas tellement confiance
en moi parce que c'est que j'aime pas
c'est quand même assez coureurs et elle
a du mal à me faire confiance
bah oui des films de cul
charge donc je savais pas s'il est
vraiment fidèle en fait non ça sent
derrière lui tout le temps sicilia soir
il va rentrer du rouge à lèvres sur les
couilles pour que jamais
c
bon je pense que vous êtes racheter
maintenant par rapport à tout ce que
vous avez fait j'espère j'espère que les
gens le voient comme ça en fait mis ma
conscience ma conscience beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui d'écouter je pense que pour
vraiment régler le problème
définitivement
on va faire une interview exclu
[Musique]
greg afin de vous excuser que
diriez-vous aux candidates qui vous avez
menti vous étiez vous étiez adorable et
j'aurais bien aimé avoir le temps de
vous connaître un peu plus chacune
ouais à votre tour c'est bien marjolaine
non non je le ne semblait pas la peine
j'ai fait le tour de france ça suffisait
tout à cambrai est ce que pour vous
excusez vous demanderiez pardon aux
femmes humiliées par le concept de ce
jeu je ne veux pas que les femmes aient
été humilié par le concept de ce jeu
parce que celles qui ont été là c'est
qu'elle voulait bien être là et je
trouve pas que quoi que ce soit
d'humiliant fin de mon point de vue à
rennes 10 milliards m quand même mais
moi je me voyais pas comme un coq parler
du voile islamique mais enfin la sacem
et des filles en avait plein qui n'était
absolument pas intéressée par moi qui se
plaisait pas et à la fin j'ai failli me
prendre un râteau alors pour 1 à rennes
pour un mec qui était censé à 30 pas
cher dans un harem s'est plutôt
transformé allender ses taux pour un
maçon ce sera
quentin ça peut servir aussi est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à vous excuser auprès
des masses ans pour l'image déplorable
je tiens je tiens à m'excuser pour le
coup de masse dans le teasing
on m'a demandé de tenir la masse comme
ça pour faire un parallèle avec le club
de golf ensuite voilà je sais tenir une
masse
excusez moi très bien oui est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à vous excuser auprès
des trafiquants de drogue pour l'image
déplorable
vous avez deux noms j'assume mais je
n'ai pas à m'excuser je pense qu'on n'a
jamais une bonne image quand on est
trafiquants malheureusement vous êtes
prêt à vous excuser auprès des
dirigeants de tf1 pour leur avoir menti
oui oui mais enfin je sais même pas si
ça vaut des excuses après tout ça allait
passer de la peau donnait la poudre aux
yeux la pluie tombée la prochaine fois
créer une page je vais changer la fin
c'est nul alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à vous excuser auprès des gens qui
vont acheter votre libre non parce que
je pense pas que je vais m'excuser
j'espère qu'ils aimeront et qui
trouveront ça c'est agréable à lire et
qui comprendront mieux certaines choses
qui ont été dites la vérité a été a été
dit voilà je me suis expliqué ça m'a
fait du bien ça m'a servi un peu de
psychothérapie en même temps et déjà
rétablies
tu espères entre des siens je n'ai
aucune idée ça pressait tu regrettes
quand même non
la mairie
10 sur le
ce
[Musique]
bonsoir maïtena guillaume depardieu
marica greg le millionnaire laurent
baffie maïtena la fille qui monte dans
le paf en ce moment un shérif pas les
seuls à six il y en a pas trop hein ah
bon ah non il n'a pas d'autre si sûr
mais qui agit comme concurrentes
il ya toutes les filles qui sont dans
l'émission aussi on a pas mal
il y a
alors maïtena depuis septembre 2001 vous
animez les maternelles sur france 5 à 8
heures 45 ce qui nous a valu un 7 d'or
le 7 d'or de la meilleure émission
éducative 2003 voilà et le dimanche vous
remettez ça avec psychologie à 13h30 une
émission consacrée à la famille aux
couples à la spiritualité et à la
sexualité vous dit quoi sur la sexualité
on parle beaucoup de sécurité surtout
sur le plateau des maternelles je dois
quand même dire à dakar ce qu'il faut
faire des enfants faut coucher
oui c'est vrai que sur le toit
et c'est dur at-talah [ __ ] mais ça se
passe si connaissions pas encore
beaucoup parler mais sa dernière
j'imagine visite quoi vous avons incité
des faits près ces écoutes sur la
sexualité sur le plateau des maternelles
on a fait le plaisir au masculin plaisir
au féminin on a intitulé sa sobrement
pour le plaisir aux familles au féminin
c'est la rédactrice en chef de
l'émission qui a intitulé sa les femmes
prennent leur plaisir en main alalalala
l'hyper 45 du matin
les femmes prennent leur plaisir en main
maïtena avait en fait commencé votre
carrière en suisse pourtant vous êtes
basque comme votre nom l'indiqué maïtena
biraben comment on dit y retrouver en
suisse à l'époque je me suis marié en
suisse a pas trente neuf raison d'y
aller quoi on travaille dans la finance
soit on épouse en suisse ouais j'ai
épousé en suisse ça n'a pas duré c'est
grave docteur
les seuls union qui dure sont celles qui
ont lieu dans des langues dans les
émissions de télé-réalité regarde le
bachelor il est toujours avec sa
gonzesse greg et tu joues avec marie cas
alors en suisse donc vous finissez par
faire une émission qui s'appelle ça
colle et ses piquants et c'est là que je
vous repère et je vous demande de venir
à paris parce que je pense vous êtes une
énorme star de la chapelle dans un
premier temps pour saint-honoré
directement il avait été acheté un truc
pour l'occasion parce que j'étais total
flipper j'allais rencontrer le garçon
que je regardais au fin fond de ma
compagne quand j'étais petit mon
meilleur je salue francis groux
instituteurs j'ai regardé lunettes et
j'avais revoilà et là je vous jure
vouloir dans un petit studio
non non mais c'était en tout bien tout
espionner vous espionnez l'heure à
laquelle je rentre et vous ne faites des
réflexions du nom voilà vous êtes rentré
tard hier à penser déçoit pas alors là
c'était un petit peu difficile on a
essayé de faire des émissions puis ce
qu'on a c'est un peu difficile on a
essayé de faire des émissions poèmes s'y
sont essayé de faire une émission pour
france 2 qui s'appelait vue sur la mer
la fête voilà jean pierre côté le
directeur des programmes étaient assez
était assez déçue je m'en excuse
jean-pierre pourtant si jean pierre
cottet qui vous engagera quelques années
plus tard sur l'a5
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes mûr pour le
succès je pense pensée ouais c'est parce
que ça y est je pense que toutes ces
années comme ça d'apprentissage de
thierry vous le pensiez déjà il ya sept
ans le problème c'est de savoir ce que
vous êtes prête à faire maïtena pour
arriver au top
à part ça chez masi est ce que tu peux
faire d'autres concessions alors vous
seriez prête comme ça pour arriver au
top a passé une semaine dans un
conteneur de télé réalité avec des gens
comme greg et marika non avec vous oui
nous oui
si thierry de vous faisiez nord-ouest où
l'accepterait oui
est ce que vous êtes prête pour arriver
au top à raconter vos échecs amoureux
chez mireille dumas non par le maltais
nord il faut en mettre un peu un peu de
bonne volonté mais pas tant que ça et
puis
ils sont pour la voir avec tyr et sont
d'une banalité tellement affligeante que
je pense pas que ça passionne les foules
vous n'êtes pas prête à raconter vous
échecs amoureux chez mireille dumas nous
est ce que vous êtes prêtes à poser dans
paris match en tant que fiancée bernard
montiel
ah oui ça c'est bien voilà j'ai sens de
la carrière tiges provoque j'ai mis de
l'eau dans votre vin invité thierry mais
c'est incroyable berne entend brasse est
ce que pour arriver au top cette pâte à
interviewer tiers des 100 et comment ah
oui et comment on fait une interview
alors au fil d'interviews
on change de place on change de place
c'est l'interview beaumont
oui
[Musique]
thierry ardisson te souviens tu de la
tour zizim quoi la tour zizim non c'est
à bourganeuf
mais je suis jamais vécu un beau gars là
sont barrées non tu connais pas le code
postal non plus n'ont même 323,4 sans te
souviens tu dises la bia non mais si les
petits gâteaux que moi j'aime marseille
qui est bien non 8e et cela bien alors
thierry tu te souviens tu de milosevic
non mais si l'eau mais si c'est le nom
je te laisse le lecteur bio c'est la
plage des essais la plage des jeunes à
lise sur l'île de youth si si c'est vrai
oui et tu te souviens de la série ghost
alors est ce que tu te souviens de toi
avant de s'habiller en noir
oui alors mais je te dis en gris foncé
mais n'ont pas toujours si tu as pris ta
période entre gris clair et gris foncé
tirèrent distance que vous vous souvenez
d'une robe de votre mère une robe à
fleurs en creux tonnes quelle couleur
des grosses fleurs rouges
est-ce que vous soulevez la première
photo de votre première photo dans un
journal
oui y'a un mec avait gagné une course de
ski dans un petit village où j'habite en
haute savoie
mais c'est moi qui était en couverture
du journal parce que j'avais embrouillée
de journalistes est ce que tu te
souviens de ton jouet préféré reporter
habite bien sûr
je
en fait je comprends ce soir c'est un
peu aussi que dans certaines missions à
six mois ajouté
oui jean talbot lago avec laquelle je
jouais est ce que tu te souviens de
george harrison
je les rencontre et où georges 5 et la
barrière parce qu'en fait quand on
rencontre les gens qu'on admire vraiment
il se passe pas grand chose en fait on
leur dit qu'on les admire et lisse très
bien et puis voilà quoi ils s'en foutent
et du rijsel est ce que tu te souviens
de taxes pape a ouï dire que chaque fois
que mes enfants prennent un dessert je
taxe ni cuillère l'été leur dis donc
taxe voit pas c'est normal tu sais que
tu dis il ya deux types de femmes dans
la ville et mère protectrice et les
[ __ ] de fruits au dessus de laquelle
lesquels tu préfères ça dépend des
moments
ça dépend des moments te souviens-tu de
l'île dardy de talia et de titien oui
linda hardy ont tiré les rois tu t'en
souviens bien demandé de passer sous la
table pour dire qu'à quai à qui était la
part elle l'a mal pris et talia et issia
et puis fanny
oui très bien je me souviens très bien
d'elle surtout de titia si tu me
regardes site web te souviens tu tires
et pour finir uniquement de ce qui te
dérange non est ce qui t'arrange aussi
ouais je suis maman je m'en souviens
bien
ce qui me dérange je m'en souviens pas
te souviens tu de tes rêves d'enfants
oui d'être là merci thierry est bien
sorti tu peux europe leur faire quand tu
veux
qu'est ce qu'en pense laurent tu pense
qu'elle peut tu pense qu'elle peut y
arriver
non non c'est pas facile de te remplacer
c'était intéressant on a appris plein de
trucs sur toi moi j'étais simplement
aimé ce que j'ai vu leur état peut
arriver aussi un meilleur
au course et maintenant
[Musique]
sappi jeu
m
voici car des minarets
hervé vilard bonsoir bonsoir l'europe
aux bisous
alors évidemment bon soir d'abord un
mail un mail très énervé d'un collectif
d'habitants de capri qui disent ouais
hervé vilard ça serait pas plus de toit
qui serait finie mais là non pour
l'instant je chante à pigalle ça se
passe bien tout va bien voilà et ben non
moi effectivement toujours là avec un
nouveau cd
mais avant d'en parler je voudrais
rafraîchir la mémoire aux plus jeunes
d'entre nous didier
[Musique]
elle arrive
pour elle
bravo
oh
[Musique]
au camp
nous
ce pays
un show
rogen
paris
oui
[Musique]
mais
le signal d'un point qui lui tout en
vous du navire selon balussou
oui
bien l'enfant killer
la plus
mais saint amour ancien allié pas
l'habitude
chien qui fait très saine
une fille vendu nos services
elles sont mal connus
m
6 alors mes biens
[Applaudissements]
ah oui à
un client pourrait revenir à un veinard
le dernier morceau combien entendre
signal est extrait de votre nouveau cd
qui s'appelle cri du coeur ou vous
chantez 12 poète du 20e siècle
plus une chanson de vous ce qui fait
treize au total
voilà voilà mais pourquoi ce titre on se
tutoie je préfère conviviale
oui je pourrais france d'études je me
sentirai vue mais oui mais un merci tout
va bien c'est simple tu interprètes
aussi une chanson de ta grande fan
marguerite duras sindia sont garés faut
savoir que marguerite duras adoré capri
c'est fini et qu'elle écrivait des
lettres à hervé je possède qui sont très
belles lettres de margueron bolide
correspondant oui mais je ne dévoilerai
pas ceux ci et voilà donc dans cet album
il ya aussi alabama song de brèches
qu'il ya du jaune et du ionesco du pré
vert du neruda il ya un vallon inédit de
younes 1 c'est un inédit que je suis
aller fourrer nocera juillet dans l'est
dans les tiroirs
une chanson qui s'appelle les fantômes
mon ami tu es la boulette c'est quoi une
boulette de shit
non mais c'est tuer c'est une affaire
entre lui et moi j'avais les larmes
quand il veut discréditer tous liés y
est voilà voilà
il ya cet album avec ses douces poète du
20e siècle
et puis à la scène le théâtre de dix
heures jusqu'au 20 mars et mogador les 5
et 6 juin voilà pour la fête des mères
pour la fête parce que je chante
toujours pour la fête des mères rien du
20 mars jusqu'à des heures de mon ami
elena qui m'a dit hervé vilard et en
concert j'ai pris les places venez venez
mon ami vous allez voir c'est très très
beau et les musiciens vous me
reconnaîtrez pas c'est un lifting à ma
façon c'était une manière de faire un
lifting question lifting en tout cas
c'est bien une série c1 ça se voit par
des châtillons la une les chambres
d'hervé vilard légende daredevil à nous
allons maintenant la faire découvrir à
nos amis les plus jeunes
guillaume est ce que vous connaissez la
légende d'hervé vilard mais on a les
jambes dont la légende dharréville
abhervé est né en 1946 le 24 juillet
dans un taxi en direction de l'hôpital
saint-antoine et ce qui est incroyable
c'est encore un signe marica vous en
conviendrez il est né dans un taxi sa
mère allait accoucher à l'hôpital
saint-antoine et quelques années plus
tard il découvrira que son père qu'il ne
connaissait pas à l'époque la course de
taxi
c'est un signe comment mais je m'en fous
totalement de skhirat
pas vous
c'est le seul cas de bons clients
ça veut dire que grâce à cette carte
pouvait revenir quand vous voulez même
si je savais rien avant droit oui
excusez moi tu peux revenir quand tu
veux harvey mais grâce à cette carte
balle a alors votre père en fait c'était
un beau parleur séducteur qui avait en
gros c'est votre maman et toutes les
femmes du quartier appelé blanche avant
de se faire la malle et et votre mère se
retrouve tout seul dans un pièce un son
confort au dessus d'un garage et puis
elle fait plein de boulot minable à
montreuil
voilà et vous vous raconter un petit peu
comme ça en dix ans elle était vendeuse
de violette mais en fait elle a fait des
boulots bien pire que ça bon mais c'est
vrai que vendeuse de violette c'est
assez poétique pour sa maman qu'elle
vendait des violettes des partitions des
chocolats c'est un personnage de deux
des enfants du paradis s'est aperçu que
votre mère ça ça te regarde pas nous
allons vers le bas non plus je pense que
guillaume du boulot il est bon alors
voilà ta mère un jour est dénoncé comme
alcoolique par une par une voisine qui
avait sans doute été la maîtresse de ton
père donc c'était un tracteur la fois
noté parce que ça devient compliqué non
c'est ça et valence et exhale la
jalousie quoi il est amer et déçu de ces
droits maternelle et tu te retrouves
dans un orphelinat saint vincent de paul
tu te souviennes numéro 74 non assise
non 74 avenue denfert rochereau je te
parles de ton numéro d'inter 760 bravo
les vagues parfaites 164 exactement 764
voilà et alors les avions une petite
médaille en avec des bois en fait un
numéro nous portions le moi je portais
le numéro sept cent soixante quatre mois
on nous fourguer comme ça voilà quand tu
es à saint vincent de paul il y avait ce
qu'on appelle la punition piqûres et
étudie j'étais persuadé qu'on faisait
des expériences médicales sur les
enfants et les ouates j'en suis même pas
j'en aurais je reste persuadé c'est pour
ça que je vais rester si jeune et que je
n'ai pas fait glisser sans vincent de
paul était et est utilisé comme twilight
c'était fréquent quand même le bbc le
gélat je sais pas quoi c'était quand
même assez fréquentes
tatavel bcg ans montaient sur les
couvertures pas que pour ça d'ailleurs
mais on nous disait on se levait c'était
notre hantise mon cas en ville a pas des
jeunes et donc ont déjà battu c'était
fréquent
une fois par semaine on avait le droit à
la psychose le cyclisme voilà alors
c'est l'époque donc où tu inventes un
faux-pas pas parce que comme tu es tout
seul tu tu racontes tes copains
d'orphelinats que ton père c'est jean
vilar au tnp et du mexique tout cet
homme là et tu mets des photos de jean
vilar dans ta chambre
comment il cessa et de gérard philipe
non il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
savent ce que jacques gerber lever la
main ce qu'il savait
enfin quand tu es très connu à la
légende dans les villages sont plus
connus que je pense qu'une à mâcher et
donc c'est l'époque effectivement où le
président rené coty décide d'envoyer les
orphelins dans des familles paysannes à
la campagne c'est ça et tu te retrouves
dans le berry chesnais naissent au fin
fond du berry chesser voilà chez nénesse
ximenes auxiette
voilà qui ne buvaient pas que du petit
lait alors le problème c'est qu'il faut
faire sept kilomètres à pied pour aller
à l'école 7 kilomètres à pied pour
revenir
witi fait 14 ce qui fait qu'à ça et je
vais ajouter pour être gay en sabots en
somme il a un jour effectivement thomas
marre de faire ses 14 kilomètres à pied
en sabots et tu passes devant chela
louise la louise c'était ce qu'on
appelle à la campagne une absente c'est
à dire il ya elle hurlait après le ciel
après le bon dieu en hurlant comme ça
avec une perche immense en inde où
viennent 28 28 et elle avait encore les
jupons blanc et tout ça une espèce de
deux berrichonne
une femme assez hélas luis tu savais où
elle cachait son pognon et je lui ai
piqué sont pas dus à piquer son pognon
enfin 50 francs ou cinq francs je me
souviens points 50 francs effectivement
soûles et sous les draps et appliquer
ces 50 mal tourner été acheté des vraies
chaussures vavin déchausser pour quitter
ses sabots oui mais alors là tu es viré
parce qu'il faut savoir puisqu'on est
dans les confidences comme ça tu en
feras ce que tu voudras après on se
côtoie diffusé là ça les arrangeait bien
que j'ai fait cette connerie parce que
ma mère me recherchait et à chaque fois
qu'elle situe à la famille dans laquelle
j'étais placé on me changer de famille
mais voilà les salopards tu leur en veux
je leur en veux pas mais je les plains
et j'espère que ça n'arrive pas aux
enfants aujourd'hui ce dont je doute
encore fort voilà donc après tu fugue
énormément tu deviens jeunes fugueurs
c'est comme ça que tu te retrouves à
paris à un peu dire voleurs aussi à
pigalle
oui alors là tu fais des courses pour
les mac pour les prostituées tu emmènes
les perruques des prostituées à c'est
chez le coiffeur tu promènent leur chien
enfin tu deviens un petit peu le chéri
de scellage allait faire nettoyer les
bas couture je m'occupais des perruques
oranges et perruque noire dépérit cube
c'était ses premières mini jupe que j'ai
vu avant la mode des minijupes et je
m'occupais aussi de nettoyer un peu le
bordel c'est vrai et on me planquer à
l'époque dans le placard oui ça c'est
graziella ajouté recherché par les flics
et graziella te plantes dans le placard
la femme à coco voilà qui s'était coco
coco c'était le plus grand truand de
pigalle avec et c'est un homme un et
c'est un monsieur que je salue encore
aujourd'hui parce qu'il m'a tendu la
main
non mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque en
même temps un vrai voyou c'est dire que
tu passes par les toits pour piquer des
chaînes stéréo
tout à fait j'ai payé quelques
appartements et c'est là que tu
rencontres daniel cordier ancien
secrétaire de jean moulin qui était
devenu galeristes et il te dit que tu
rentres l'orphelinat et moi je te sors
de là exact où grâce à la lgv est devenu
ton tuteur légal mais je
j'aurais pu très bien ne pas le croire
et ne pas retourner en orphelinat sellal
a le coup de pot ouais elle lui a fait
confiance je les fais j'y suis allé
j'avais pas envie d'aller acheter et
lâché cordier tu croises quand même tout
le gratin parisien lors de déjeuners
auquel tu es invité tue un excellent le
fou je disais toujours à wang tu te
souviens nous angle le cuisinier daniel
cordier très très bien il est là le
fouillent là le fruit je disais il est
encore là le faut parce que tous les
jours j'ai été tenus d'aller déjeuner
chez lui c'était la loi il était devenu
mon tuteur légal devant la loi donc
j'allais déjeuner il est encore là c'est
lui qui se croisent les mains qui
équipent parle dans sa barbe guînes qui
se comprend pas qui peut style en son
assiette et tu peux dire qu'il s'était
c'était andré malraux voilà il
m'emmerdait profondément allait vendre
malraux il est mendès france et les
chaban delmas relie les rangs et
vraiment dsk l'époque tu as appris qui a
dénoncé jean moulin je sais mais je ne
le dirai pas tu le sais ça ne me regarde
pas et qui a avalé laurent g
voilà et donc grâce à cordier tu trouve
un boulot de marchands de disques aux
champs elysées au lit douchez symphonia
chez sa femme chez symphonia tu prends
des cours de chant des cours de comédie
et si là que tu change de nom parce
qu'en fait le vrai nom d'hervé vilard
c'est c'est rené reconnaît rené villa
hervé ce soit mes initiales mais oui tu
enlèves à la vie l'art pour que ce soit
plus gros sur la fiche tout ça c'est
bien
oui et puis là c'est le drame
non pas du tout c'est là que c'est
arrivé là il fait un premier différend
premier disque qui s'appelle une voix
qui t'appelle et personne ne l'entend
oui exactement pour contrer au cou c'est
le deuxième qui marche
et
alors comment hervé vilard a trouvé
l'idée de cette chanson déjà métro tu
vois une affiche avec marc et partez en
vacances à capri pour 2000 francs ouais
donc tu vois ça et à l'époque et une
chanson de d'aznavour qui disaient c'est
fini fini fini interactif et partez en
vacances à capri fini fini
capri c'est fini et je vais te dire
qu'au pouvoir et je vais te dire
pourquoi les chiens d'autres trucs dans
le métro du bonheur ça m'intéresse pas
non je te dire pourquoi parce qu'à
l'époque claude françois voulait quitter
sa maison de disques
on voulait faire de moi le nouveau
claude françois me faire chanter des
chansons américaines en france est la
nation apparaissant en allée des
chansons comme ça je savais pas le faire
moi j'aimais mouloudji j'aimais tout ça
donc pour prouver à daniel cordier que
j'étais capable d'écrire des chansons
j'étais un autodidacte j'ai écrit ma
petite chanson comme ça dans ma petite
chambre de bonne et je me suis inspiré
des chansons d'amour que j'entendais à
l'époque alors que tout le monde faisait
yéyé ou après tout ce que tu veux c'est
est donc là tu deviens une star
incroyable événement un succès fou et là
laurent tapotage cela c'est horrible
c'est horrible c'est horrible france
dimanche ça commence mal retrouves ta
maman c'est vrai il est france dimanche
soir quand tu reviens dans sa chambre
d'hôtel
ils me l'ont ramené à verdun voilà donc
un verdun tu sors du du gala tu rentre à
l'hôtel tu tombes sur ta mère évidemment
tu l'as pas vu depuis je suis pas
combien d'années et 20 ans
au minimum ap voilà et à ce moment là au
moment où tu l'embrassa c'est pire que
la télé réalité est là c'est pire que
tout pour la toux les placards source et
le délire les flashs crépitent et il ya
plein de photographes qui sont là et qui
oui c'est l'horreur c'est ça mais tu as
été victime comme de genre de truc assez
régulièrement parce qu'il ya aussi le
faux suicide a voulu que je me suicide
organisé par gilles paquet cercle mais
en fait ils ont fait croire qu'ils ctu à
l'époque dans france dimanche c'était
comme ça ils ont fait croire que tu
s'était suicidé en fait je me suis pas
susciter j'ai fait simplement une petite
crise de nerfs en sortant de scène parce
que j'avais bossé depuis six mois que
j'avais pas dormi que ouais je suis mais
peut-être un peu trop tu fumé quoi s'est
penché à l'appel du premier ils ont
titré j'étais dit que je ne disait
jamais rien je ne dénoncerai jamais
personne j'ai quand même pas te dire qui
me donnait la marchandise plus guillaume
depardieu pour être motivé voilà et l'a
donc tu retrouves ta mère tu es s'est
occupé d'elle tu l'envoies chez le
coiffeur et rallye prend goût et il va 2
3 fois par semaine
elle y prend goût gilles bordeaux voilà
tu labit tulle ou un appartement mais
c'est un échec parce que finalement
comme tu dis on peut pas refaire la vie
de quelqu'un à 60 ans il va faire
profiter de tout ce que tu avais mais
non ce fut un échec pour l pascal
culpabilisait
ce que j'étais devenu elle voulait elle
voulait pas d'argent elle voulait rien
elle veut continuer sa vie je vais dire
de pauvres femmes et l
je me souviens de lui avoir offert des
manteaux du guanaco cherono marc legault
est un camélidé oui ça se mérite et la
vigogne ou de la nar ouais ça fait des
bonds mentaux ah oui c'est de la laine
surtout on ne tue pas l'animal est très
bon et puis elle s'en foutait totalement
s'est intéressé c'est comme les gens des
bonnes années avec lucienne boyer dans
les rues près est alors un jour tu
reçois un petit mot de jean de propriano
en corse qui te disent votre père est
enterré ici monsieur baglioni et
enterrés ici
voilà c'est en fait un italien qui était
parti à paris qui avait séduit ta main
et qui avait été donc ton père mais
comme il était déjà marié en corse
il était revenu en abandonnant sa mère
ouais c'est une drôle d'histoire
laisse tomber la neige ça c'est adamo
alors aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est
finie qu'est ce qui n'est pas fini les
faux suicide c'est fini moi je me suis
jamais suicidé
ouais j'ai exagéré surtout comme tout le
monde j'ai trouvé dans les grandes deux
fois lui tournée mondiale c'est fini ah
oui oui les boîtes c'est fini pas
souvent parce que j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver comme un vieux ringard c'est
quand j'étais jeune je sortais beaucoup
là je sais que je rentrais plus tôt à 10
heures du matin c'est souvent un mur
samba tout ça ou je te croiser au fond
celle à l'époque je voyais de quelques
vieux salopards qui traînait comme ça je
voudrais je me disais je ne ferais je ne
traînerai pas dans l'est quand j'avais
leur âge je traînerai pas la régate tue
sans plus non je vis au presbytère
l'exorciser cultive ma solitude
donc les boîtes c'est fini la drogue
c'est fini c'est fini
ah oui aussi oui le sexe c'est fini
c'est fini
kiki oui l'isf non
j'étais dire hervé fiche c'est
incroyable j'ai 58 ans 58 ans t'as pas
tellement changé finalement je peux
chanter en espagnol comme un gladiateur
vie rien non mais on va faire une
interview il n'est pas changé
à bévilard qu'est ce qui a changé depuis
tout ce temps dans votre coiffure qu'est
ce qui a changé
j'ai fait comme toi je me les suis coupé
ouais ouais moi que moi quand même un
moins que moi
elles sont pas totalement contente quand
je les coupe tron
enfin le 2 mai admiratrice du brut et
copines et moi tu te fait teindre les
cheveux ou quoi jamais ouais c'est bien
vrai encore et c'est ça sent le cirage
et la gueule toi qu'est ce que vous lui
la paix ce bon pote hervé danton sourire
qu'est ce qui a changé
je n'aimais pas une carie un peu jaune
parce que je club beaucoup 1 1 dans tes
opinions politiques qu'est ce qui a
changé
je rêve je vais te de répondre très
sincèrement aujourd'hui j'ai très envie
de voter à gauche
ah oui le pain bien tu vas voter pour
françois hollande quand même nom mais si
jacques lang se présente je voterai pour
lui d'accord bien dans tes rêves qu est
ce qu elle changé j'ai jamais énormément
rêver
j'ai pas changé pas beaucoup rêvé me
suis accroché je suis un accro de la vie
constamment réveiller même quand je dors
dans tes colères qu'est ce que changer
je m'appelle hervé vilard et temps en
temps je m'appelle énervé villa voilà et
on m'appelle aussi énervé wisla à
develop développe dans tes plaisir
qu'est ce qui a changé dans mes plaisirs
j'ai toujours eu très sincèrement et je
le dis avec l'euro le plus mon vrai
bonheur c'est de chanter c'est mon vrai
plaisir
mais le sexe tu sais je vais te dire
j'aime pas trop là la salive le [ __ ]
tout ça ça matin avant non non non je
trouve ça désolant
7° j'aime pas fait vrai non non je sais
trés trés guillon c'est comme les
escargots je trouve ça dégueulasse
commandé un aussi bon là on a tout faux
tirer de l'année
j'ai dit que je voulais aller chez
ardisson quand je vais chez ardisson
j'ai fait une émission d'ardisson une
fois tous les dix ans j'espère qu'il
sera encore là dans dix ans alors venir
méfier oui et à capri qu'est ce qui a
changé
alors là c'est devenu de plus en plus
dégueulasse sauf que je suis citoyen
d'honneur de la rb quelque part capri
c'est fini c'est vraiment toi mais je
vais te dire je t'emmerde toi
[Musique]
non
chante tout spoil du monde
messieurs
[Musique]
ce que je peux me permettre d'être
interrompre donc aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est la saint valentin
absolument j'avais pensé à faire une
petite surprise à ma chérie
j'attendais
un greg et ça c'est de la merde je veux
dire à tous avec un bouquet les les ce
et seule union qui dure sont celles qui
naissent devant des caméras je vais
finir par le croire
c'est fort entre bull à la whey là il
vient briser tous les sons à cette date
les civils a marqué repose en paix tu as
marqué je t'aime
tellement donné
à la seule femme qui est sûr c'est
gentil ça que ses jeunes années
avant il faut demander là c est là qu
est la route peut-être ça c'était
vachement s'il ne touche pas je sais
ouais
bravo non seulement il est amoureux mais
en plus ils étaient interchangeables
alors moi je dis non
la non est un mois encore tu peux passer
neuro c'est pour mon copain je peux
poser la question oui c'est quoi les
chandelles aux subtils du rox cherche
pas alors c'est vrai que je ne sors plus
je pense laiterie copains tous les deux
bien sûr j'aime beaucoup ces pièces à
j'ai vu sa pièce elle est bien sa pièce
c'est un mec qui bosse beaucoup il est
10e au belle pièce mêle pièce même
d'ailleurs à le dire les pères de
famille oui bon en même temps je pourrai
lui d'autres fins alors guillaume oui
moi te laisser elle était couchée
oui bien sûr
toujours en ce moment non non je tombe
bientôt
ouais je prépare ouais tu prends ton
élan
oui c'est sûr merci d'avoir été avec
dieu
sur le pont
et
non non non non
j'accueille maintenant katherine pancol
[Musique]
katherine pancol bonsoir acceptes tu
m'as rose
je préfère blanche mais large et là
c'est triste et malheureux c'est une
chanson c'est aujourd'hui dimanche ma
jolie voix si des roses blanches qui les
aime tant
ah elle est triste cette chanson
bien catherine vous connaissez tous le
monde c'est une maison bleue chez à la
colline on est bien d'un pied ce qui me
veulent un dessert new spark anti vie
chère madame je vous en prie
catherine bonsoir donc journalistes à
cosmopolitan à paris match et puis un
jour en 1979 robert laffont lui même
vous appelle pour vous dire qu'il adore
vos articles vous suggère d'écrire un
roman ce sera moi d'abord trois cent
mille exemplaires un succès énorme
phénomène de société
et puis en 1980 à barbare et depuis une
dizaine d'autres voilà le dernier chez
albin michel s'appelle embrassez moi
alors on y retrouve vos thèmes habituels
et puis un certain nombre de révélations
qui concerne votre rencontre et votre
amitié avec louise brooks alors louise
brooks vous avez demandé de rien publié
pendant 20 ans c'est voilà ça fait vingt
ans donc aujourd'hui vous publiez alors
louise brooks en fait on connaît deux
films on connaît loulou et le journal
d'une fille perdue c'est tout c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est immensément connu et
pourtant on en parle souvent et et les
très jeunes connaissent louise brooks sa
coupe de cheveux la frange tout ça quoi
c'est un personnage qui est toujours
actuelle elle a été relancée je pense
par la pub cacharel le parfum oui c'est
ça et puis il ya eu lui donnerait pas
que ce qui a été le dessinateur italien
qui en a fait une bande dessinée
donc elle est passée un peu à travers
tous les
oui aujourd'hui c'est une espèce d'icône
comme ça que les gens connaissent louise
rouchon dit elle à la coupe louise
brooks
et puis on connaît aussi ses conquêtes
masculines qui étaient fort nombreux ce
qu'on va le voir
alors vous vous l'avez découvert non pas
à travers ses films passés à vous les
aviez vu j'imagine la travers un livre
je vais me balader sur la cinquième
avenue à new york et vous tombez sur un
bouquin de ce que vous achetez
j'ai été impressionné par la manière
dont elle écrit
abbado ce moment-là vous ressentez
presse de d'impérieuses nécessités de la
rencontre la rencontre et voilà donc je
me suis d'abord ans les séances étaient
vivantes ou mortes ensuite où elle
habitait si on pouvait la rencontre est
en fait elle recevait plus personne
depuis 15 ans et en fait j'ai fait que
je passe par paris par des journalistes
français pour arriver à la localiser que
je vive le roi déjà qui dirige l à
l'époque vous dis moi si tu fais un
reportage sur facebook je le publie
voilà et puis aussi vous trouvez un
étudiant qui fait ses courses qui a les
clés de son appartement
donc vous arrivez à la rencontrer elle
vit à rochester en recluse à l'époque
dans un tout petit appartement dans un
tout petit appartement d'un petit hlm à
banlieue de rochester a déjà crocheteurs
c'est pas gai mais la banlieue c'est
encore moins gai et donc à samedi
après-midi j'arrive chez elle avec une
bouteille de champagne vous vivez plus
est un grand concours de chanel numéro 5
et j'étais très très très impressionné
je me suis retrouvé face à aux mythes
croître et elle avait donc à l'époque 75
ans elle était assise comme ça très très
droite
dans son lit avec une petite liseuse
rose et puis j'ai commencé à lui
il pose des questions j'avais préparé un
interview et puis à un moment dans
l'interview elle est là s'est mise à me
parler
et contrairement aux autres visiteurs de
louise brooks vous lui parlez pas
d'hollywood parce qu'elle avait marre
quand on lui parle de ça les gens
venaient voir le phénomène de foire et
en fait vous comporter d'une façon assez
différente et de là naîtra une amitié
qui durera deux ans et demi dans la
première rencontre elle est sur un lit
elle est malade à la une maladie
pulmonaire à la l'emphysème well
emphysème pulmonaire et vous dit à l'ats
on dirait un petit mois nous comme ça
avec un oeil noir très noir très
personnel il avait une manière de l
avait un sourire comme ça très ironique
qui rapide parce que là je crois qu'elle
était elle était très fatiguée en même
temps très sarcastique sur sa vie papa
est gris niamey remet
à santés kalana victimes alors elle vous
dit j'aurais voulu être écrivain
et si j'avais écrit un livre ça se
serait appelée fabrication d'une merde
et elle vous dit est ce que vous vous
n'avez jamais le sentiment d'être qu'une
merde et vous dites oui j'ai souvent
l'impression d'être une imposture
hélas cette attitude que vous avez
envers elle fait qu'elle vous portent de
l'intérêt et de la tension et finalement
de l'amitié et un renversement
face à ce moment là c'est elle qui a
commencé à me poser plein de questions
écrit au bout de ces trois quatre heures
qu'on était ensemble allemagne et ceux
pouvant venir demain son image
ensuite vous revenez l'avoir en moyenne
un week-end par mois vous lui donnez des
barbes du cube est vachement bien d'als
et c'est que c'est que ces courageux
vous aider ma rue laver les cheveux
voulu couper les ongles des crises et
non mais c'est vrai qu'il faut avoir
envie de s'occuper de quelqu'un est là
elle vous demande de l'appeler tous les
jours à 14h30 ce que vous faites
elle vous demande de raconter les
moindres détails de votre vie et tous
les jours à 14h30
même quand vous êtes au restaurant vous
lever de table et vous allez l'appeler
pour le voir et quand vous nous raconter
votre vivre lui raconter votre vie
entière
ils voulaient tout savoir je vais fans
chair fraîche quoi c'est à dire que je
pense qu'elle est
étaient coupés du monde depuis trop
longtemps et moi j'étais un peu ça
peut-être chercheuse vous viviez à sa
place elle vivre par procuration sont
passés moi j'aime raconter ce que mon
présent à temps s'il te plaît c'est
compliqué et quand vous l'appelez à
14h45 elle vous engueuler est assez
irascible a alors voilà alors elle vous
fait un certain nombre de révélations
sur son enfance qui sont assez étonnante
puisque c'est des choses qui n'ont
jamais été et est racontée et on
comprend mieux le personnage de louise
brooks et ce qu'elle a incarné à
l'époque quand vous nous dévoiler
finalement qu'elle a été abusée
sexuellement très jeune wen neuf ans
ouais elle faisait pas de pathos ou à
utiliser
bon d'accord j'étais
oui j'ai été abusé mais elle dit ça en
même temps j allais oui oui parce
qu'elle n'était pas aussi télé tier 1
s'est donc sa maman tous les matins ils
disaient tu vas et y aller
et ensuite il a toujours recherché à
travers ses amants ce mélange de douleur
et de plaisir qu'elle avait connu avec
le premier mec donc avec celui qui même
dans la vie parce que dès qu'elle arrive
à construire quelque chose de skype app
salle a commencé à construire une
carrière magnifique
mais les loups mots ça t'a vu un succès
non des cas commencent à construire
quelque chose de bien il fallait qu'elle
détruise derrière alors effectivement
ceci explique cela c'est à dire qu'elle
disait chaque homme qui me menaçait
devenez un maître dont je ne pouvais me
défaire d'un côté portier de nuit un peu
à tout à fait ça et alors il suffisait
que ses amants retrouve le ton de de son
abuseur de ses 9 ans pour qu'elle leur
obéissent vous dis je n'ai jamais aimé
que des hommes cruels
on ne tombe pas amoureux donne gentil
c'est rare que des femmes raconte ça
parce qu'on sait que ça existe mais
c'est très rare que ça soit racontée
d'une façon aussi cru à mais louisa
l'été elle l avait elle une un amour
passionné pour la vérité elle disait
toujours à l'oeil ça explique sa
fascination pour le sexe vous pensez oui
c'est qu'on pouvait pas connaître
quelqu'un tant qu'on n'avait pas chez un
coup bas j'aimerais bien vous connaître
ça va pas je le droit va rentrer parce
que tu mènes
ça devient n'importe quoi je n'ai jamais
eu de nombreuses amendes dont charlie
chaplin nous a raconté ses amours avec
charlie chaplin en disant que c'était un
amant très raffinée à l'un des boutiques
étant un charlot vraiment très raffiné
qui veut tout essayé et c'est une femme
dépravés l élu qui comme amant à partir
de chaplin bogaert pas mal car tchernia
à mon va tout ça mais est ce que pierre
tchernia raconter cette histoire et la
dame a maintenant c'est tout le monde
raconte tout sur lui tout le monde et où
toulon je voulais savoir si monsieur
tchernia qui a écrit ses mémoires je
n'ai pas lui raconter cette histoire sur
lui donc elle vous raconte tout ça
beaucoup de goût de liberté donc en vous
demandant de publier vingt ans plus tard
et puis on apprend que son père la mater
tous les soirs pendant qu'elle prenait
son bain par le trou laissé en plus on
perd c'est un homme de loi était un
avocat kansas très très puritain et elle
savait que son père l'a regardé ce qui
fait que ça aussi ça a participé à sa
vie sexuelle plus tard c'est elle s'est
toujours sentie honteuse fautive
finalement d'être arrêté c'est ça
l'histoire est finalement son père c'est
l'homme qui l'a fait chuter d'une
certaine façon je pense je pense que
monsieur flower la c1 la bise heures
elle saignait bizarrement elle s'en est
remise
mais pas son père mais qu'est ce qu'il a
inventé pierre tchernia dans l'histoire
la partie non pas parce que c'est un
homme de cinéma je dois être au courant
de l'affairé le film is bruce comment
son fils et son fils caché pierre
tchernia que le fils que c'est j'ai un
vrai quelle qu'elle soit
je
censée nourrir et maintenant les gens
m'appellent
hélas
je ne
il omet
ouais si brian molko
[Musique]
molko laurent brian molko utilise la
carte de bons clients que deviendra donc
il vient quand il veut ça va brasser un
parti ça tiens tu peux venir quand tu
veux voilà merci
la dernière fois que tu es venu y avait
jadis tel ce soir ya hervé
vous avez un point commun tous les deux
assez car il ya absolument vous avez
plat mais au moins c'est que comme hervé
vilard tu as été brian ami avec un
prêtre ses vins voilà vous avez fait des
petits séminaires ensemble à l'époque un
signe non et puis toi le problème c'est
qu'il y ait eu raison de la découverte
la sexualité oublier les curés ouais les
curés ne ment pas ne ment pas oublier
les victimes de non non pas du tout j'ai
un métier victimes toi t'as vu moi je me
suis coupé ses gestes j'ai besoin de moi
même d'ailleurs de porter dans la
voiture bar ans ferme mais en fait c'est
peut-être cette enfance proche de ce
curé qui a fait que dernièrement tu as
fait un disque qui s'appelle sleeping
with ghosts c'est-à-dire dormir avec des
fantômes dit ce mysticisme peut-être
qu'est revenu bas j'ai toujours une
garder ça avec moi j'ai toujours
moi je suis reconnaissant de sachets je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup aidé avec avec les chrétiens
aide les métaphore biblique c'est
quelque chose de très très fort alors je
suis effet oui on peut faire une très
belle chanson il ya de très belles
choses dans la bible à chanter
maintenant habile il ya plein d'inceste
violent jacques perrin c'est que mon
gaza il ya ça aussi c'est intéressant
parce qu'ils sont allés vraiment creusé
au fond des choses
cette dernière fois brian molko s'est
très bien entendu que ces chaînes distel
et ce soir je pense que tu vas très bien
attendre le quart d'heure villa c'est
quand même une mission
ces démissions du choc des cultures
alors cet album sleeping with ghosts est
réédité avec dix reprises de grands
standards internationaux
il ya johnny et mari de robert palmer il
ya melody nelson de serge gainsbourg
daddy cool de boney m tkm extraordinaire
de voir placebo qui joue du bonnet m et
puis aussi la réédition en français d'un
morceau qui s'appelle protect mif la
moelle iron qui s'appelle protège moi en
français avec des paroles de virginie
despentes didier
[Musique]
je suis
g
[Musique]
alors version anglaise
garçons française ça
elle échoué
[Musique]
placebo balshaw
la loi
et alors marcia le dvd qui sort qui
s'appelle seul max né lors d'un live in
paris ce le premier demi live de placebo
le concert à paris voilà alors l'europe
là je veux lancer un magnéto parce qu'on
va voir un extrait du dvd dont je viens
de parler et puis j'ai plus le magnéto
serge qu'est-ce que tu suggères orlando
marc landeau gelé plus non plus il a plu
il a viré car vais m'attacher erreur
algérien un magnéto serge diot ouais
voilà c'est placebo live in taris le
début
sort le 16 mars mesdames messieurs voilà
alors depuis que vous êtes venu brian
dans cette émission est à peu près un an
j'ai lu un article une interview avec
etienne daho dans rolling stones et vous
vous énervez contre la télé réalité
vous dites que si une insulte à la pop
vous dites ça devrait pas s'appeler à la
recherche de la nouvelle star par
exemple ça devrait s'appeler à la
recherche du nouveau chanteur de karaoké
c'est qui qui en profite ouais vraiment
c'est celle d'accompagner le téléphone
c'est la maison de disques
et puis c'est la compagnie de télé c'est
pas vraiment inspiré brut et imposer un
cessez ça toujours été une histoire de
pognon il ya toujours eu un type qui
étaient là derrière pour ramasser le
pognon claude françois ou qui tu veux
même si tu les connais pas
ou lucienne boyer ou les îles sont pas
ramassés le magot d'abord je sais man
ray de gens qui
on ne fait pas ce métier avec la
télévision la télévision n'est pas
représentatif de notre métier nous qu'il
est en train de bien c'est pas qu'on
fait pas ce métier des bisons il dit
maintenant c'est la télévision qui fait
ce métier non c'est faux c'est faux
totalement faux je connais des artistes
sont des musiciens extraordinaires du
nord il s'appelle ils s'appellent les
mauvaises langues
il chante devant 3000 personnes ils sont
jamais passés à la télé 1
il ya un public en france extraordinaire
il tant qu'il y aura du linge aux
fenêtres tant qu'on pourra chanter
danser votre jamais la star academy sur
ma vie de star académie pourquoi pas à
la limite je ne pense que les membres
ont le droit de rêver
par contre le droit de revendiquer les
mots a pas de rêver d'accrocher de
revendiquer c'est de changer dit lui
même coiffure qu'hervé villard
aujourd'hui c'est ce grand mère dans non
ce qui s'y fait ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui
lui dis que finalement il ya le show
business est lié à la télé qui est lié à
une compagnie de téléphone mais est
finalement tout ça show business a
chanté le show business n'a jamais été
dans la chanson thierry le show business
il est ailleurs il est pas dans la
chanson ferait la différence est que la
différence c'est que les gens vraiment y
pense que ils ont droit d'être célèbres
sont pas bosser c'est ça c'est ça et je
pense que c'est ça que la france
recherchent une star et star académie
c'est ça c'est l'idée qui met en mai
tête des jeunes
alors on a créé un malaise social qui
est la jalousie de la célébrité et
à l'âge de 21 ans là les jeunes filles
se rencontrent qui m'ont pas se marier
avec le capitaine de l'équipe de
football d'angleterre david beckham par
exemple et puis il tombe dans la
dépression c'est un malaise futur elle
je pense et les gens oublient qu est la
musique n'est pas à une compétition de
popularité c'est moi je pense si c'est
la violence j'ai eu un moment où les
gens j'en pense que vraiment que le
rock'n'roll par exemple c'est que le
sexe drogue et rock'n'roll bien sûr que
ça existe dans ce monde là mais c'est de
la bosse vraiment on passe 18 - en
tournée en ce cas c'est cuit pour vendre
des disques des mourides il a existé
avant toi bien sûr et toi tu as donné
avant moi aussi il t'a donné de la
musique qui t'a donné la musique et
écoute lou reed moi je ça peut paraître
étonnant mais je nourris depuis très
longtemps et est pas né quand je crois
pas arrivé à vos réponses et que son
succès sur l'a36 ça va j'écouterai 110
ouais ouais mais julien après partager à
50/50
alors voyez vous êtes devenu célèbre en
transformant votre angoisses
d'adolescent le teenage angst en art et
on va voir comment ça s'est passé
on va faire une interview trash
[Musique]
enrico à partir de quel âge avez vous
commencé à vous maquiller un vers l'âge
de 11 ans a les bains je faisais du
théâtre à l'école alors j'ai toujours
associé la scène avec le maquillage je
vous ai déjà porté string en cuir
inscrits en cuir non jamais oui bah
ouais tu dénonces estrie bordeaux a oui
quand tu étais c'était pour nous boya
est ce que vous avez déjà vu du sang
jamais ouais j'ai une copine
j'avais une copine il ya 5 6 ans qui a
vu m'ont semblé j'ai jamais vu tant de
quelqu'un d'autre avait pas des dons en
un an
est ce que tu as déjà porter des
menottes ailleurs que dans un
commissariat
oui bien et toi est-ce que tu étais déjà
filmé en train de faire l'amour
jamais non j'ai pas envie que ça se
retrouve sur internet
est ce que tu as déjà sucer des talons
aiguilles non jeu léché les bottes
mais si c'est des talons aiguilles est
ce que tu as déjà partagé une copine
avec des potes ou l'inversé du pis en
sachant non est ce que tu as déjà porté
des vêtements de ta mère oui voilà ce
soutien gorge a été sûr j'ai été sur est
ce que tu sais déjà automutilée ouais
autres tous ici j'aimerais bien me roy
et la capacité de me de fer l'auto
fellation et puis je me
avis aux pattes c'est pas bon pour les
lombaires il faudrait des corps
donc est-ce que c'est déjà automutilée
ben oui oui je les fais ouais
ben j'ai beaucoup souffert ben
exclusivement d'être super salariés pour
l'instant mais je je suis dépressif chez
beaucoup souffert de ça j'ai pris pour
longtemps des médicaments pour et oies
il y avait des temps très noir dans ma
vie où je me suis auto mutilée
automutilée
je me retrouvais dans des chambres des
chambres d'hôtel et jusqu'à six des
vingt et je fais mes chambres mais
heureusement ça va mieux
ces jours ci oui merci ça ça bien non
mais c'est important d'en parler parce
que je pense cependant très important
que je pense que les jeunes sachent que
que des gens comme moi ont passé par des
choses dans laquelle ils passent aussi
parce que moi je souffert d'une maladie
qui est la dépression un puits
c'est ça veut pas dire que c'est pas
possible de faire quelque chose de
positif même s'il ya quelque chose qui
dans sa tête ou qui quittent arrête ou
qu'ils quittent qui te force à
travailler en eau de te battais mai et
j'espère que je suis une inspiration
pour les gens elle c'est pour ça que
j'en parle je trouve que c'est super
important
est-ce que mme royal est ce que tu t'es
déjà raser les poils du torse
oui bien sûr souvent way pour des
séances de photos ouais ouais c'est a dû
le faire toi c'est en semant mayer arg
de dégoût et de poils marois pourquoi
pour le scripps pas très esthétique qui
ont rendu ce jour qu'il était c'est
bizarre ce jour qu'il est mal son
indépendance le chat est ce que tu as
déjà regardé jean pierre pernaut à 13
heures
[Musique]
voilà un placebo
co sleeping with ghosts édition de
monsieur le single s'appelle protège moi
avec des paroles de virginie despentes
et maintenant
voici stevan ossements
[Musique]
a serious man bonsoir après des
activités politiques peu recommandable à
la fin des années 70 entre l'italie et
la france
j'ai tjrs et quoi dans les brigades
rouges donc ouais enfin c'est comment
cette influence et les belles choses
chez les gauchos un homme - gauche aux
deux choses ben brik 1 2me rouge clair
père austère dakar après donc a eu six
ans po et l'ena l'école nationale
d'administration où vous avez fait l'ena
vous accepté d'en accepter dans l'est
c'était d'en parler ça peut aider tous
les jeunes qui seraient tentés par l'ena
d'avoir quelqu'un qui est passé par là
d'avoir votre témoignage
c'est quoi qui vous attirait dans les
mains de saleh s'est fait d'études
être étudiant en ayant un salaire ouais
et c'est vrai qu'elle est là on perd
tout contact avec la réalité quand on y
est on perd contact avec la réalité en
dehors de l'ena oui c'est un milieu très
fermé
c'est vrai qu'on voit plus rien on est
on est dans son monde on est un petit
peu un petit peu autiste on en est seul
avec les autres démarrant on voit on
voit ces polycopiés et on voit ses
camarades et narquois ça a été facile de
vous en sortir des frais qu'elle veut
pas en parler
non mais c'est difficile de parler de
salomé caf elena moi c'est novembre non
c'est un peu plus que ça dans ses
chroniques
mais je vais redoubler avant moi c'était
facile de vous en sortir
moyennement facile moyennement est
facile vous vous pensez que maintenant
vous êtes vous êtes dehors c'est
définitif du même genre et si on est
assez purifier où il a replongé dans les
mains je prenais c'est sûr que
diriez-vous à des jeunes stéphane qui à
tout moment peuvent tomber dans les
je pense que c'est important parce que
c'est important
enfin sega ravages des études
supérieures il ya ceux de dénoncer ce
soir l'en sérieusement vous pensez que
maintenant c'est lui non ce qui est pas
mal c'est de faire et puis après on en
sortira serment et non et que
diriez-vous à des jeunes qui seraient
tentés par l'ena est bien vigilant
courage quand même hein parce que je
vous vous êtes solide vous en être sorti
vous avez l'air bien et difficilement
difficilement voilà alors après li na
faisait travailler au ministère des
finances auprès de pierre bérégovoy puis
dans le privé vous avez été la direction
financière davasse et puis quand messi
est arrivé
vous avez décidé de prendre un petit peu
de large les produits des films 1 s'est
produit des films de catherine breillat
d'assayas des claire denis de laetitia
masson est aujourd'hui publié un livre
de l'aig
il est à mon sens il est pas maçon c'est
tf1 qui croyait qu'il était mince ans il
est très fort lui il était donc
aujourd'hui vous sortir un livre de 600
pages chez grasset qui s'appelle le
capital alors on en parle on est
descendu un peu en dessous 600 pages ça
fait 5 199 page mais oui oui c'est d'y
aller narquin alors le livre raconte
donc l'avis de marc de tournemire y
brillant énarque justement devenu pdg du
crédit général mais surtout c'est un
livre sur l'horreur du nouveau
capitalisme où finalement on est passé
de société possédée par des familles à
des entreprises possédées par des parts
des fonds de pension et posséder je
dirai au double sens du terme
on est passé du pouvoir autoritaire du
patron propriétaire au pouvoir
totalitaire des fonds de pension en les
fonds de pension ccbc des groupes qui
gèrent comme ça des centaines de
milliards de dollars que leur ont confié
des retraités américains incessamment
des retraités américains allemands et
c'est au stade us des retraités du monde
du monde entier voilà et qui ont pour
préoccupation de vivre leur retraite le
plus confortablement possible pendant
jouir le plus possible et qui de ce fait
la demande à ce que la rentabilité de
leurs placements soit le plus élevé
possible et ils confient leur intérêt à
des killers des tueurs qui sont là pour
que ça rapporte le plus possible alors
il des graisses
ils délocalisent
ils ruinent l'europe et les
esclavagistes l'asie en gros noms des
esclavagistes le monde le monde entier
il serait vas-y jeu les jeunes ceux qui
sont ici ceux qui sont en asie ceux qui
sont hors d'amérique latine ceux qui
sont en afrique pour permettre à eux
d'avoir d'avoir la ville a plus la plus
agréable possible pour contrepartie que
il faut bien que derrière la jeune
génération travaille pour leur permettre
de leur permettre de s'amuser parce que
ce qu'il se passait pas de canicule aux
états unis si si mais ils ont la
climatisation jara voilà non mais parce
que ce qui est ce qui était un peu
nouveau c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui un
troisième âge qui est qui et la
troisième âge qui est bien quelques aime
la vie qui aime s'amuser qui aime qui
aime les plaisirs de l'existence et qui
conçoit que à 70 ans on puisse encore
dans ses allées on est soixante dix ans
est encore très jeune on veut voir le
monde veut pas le monde on veut s'amuser
une en pleine forme à 70
bien voilà donc effectivement tout ça
était obligé une rentabilité maximum
d'abord les patrons qui sont obligés de
raisonner à court terme parce qu'il faut
évidemment faire plaisir aux
actionnaires est tellement un court
terme qui commence par se bourrer les
fouilles donc les primes les stock
options et votre livre commence par la
négociation d'un patron qui s'en va
parce qu'il a un cancer des testicules
il part en retraite et il négocie d'une
façon terrible son départ il lui demande
qu'on lui laisse son salaire et demande
qu'on lui laisse ses assistantes qu'on y
est la jouissance du jet privé de la
banque que sa fille de garde la
communication et quelles qu'elles
bénéficient de ce qu'on appelle un
golden parachute c'est à dire que dans
l'hypothèse où elle se fait virer à la
gagne à joli pactole à la sortie voilà
alors ça c'est du roman mais en fait ça
s'est réellement passé puisque le patron
de general motors quand il a quand il a
quitté son entreprise
il a touché un paquet de pognon qui peut
faire les 25 génération mais en plus de
ça il a demandé à garder par exemple ses
abonnements dans la presse sur le type
dit oui mais je veux qu'on continue à me
payer mes amants de la bastille au câble
mais c'est ça c'est ce qui est
d'ailleurs très romanesque en fait dans
cette situation là c'est que voilà
quelqu'un qui est probablement méritons
le patron de general motors mais au
moment où il part de la présidence de
general motors comme vous l'avez dit il
il négocie le moindre abonnement moindre
cana jusqu'à la fin de sa vie le moindre
abonnement jusqu'à la moindre chaînes
thématiques jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
donc tout est très
été très très précisément négocier au
moment où les types les types kittler
quittent leurs fonctions
alors il ya un truc dans votre bouquin
je sais pas si c'est vraiment apprend
l'existence non pas d'une prime de
licenciement et d'une prime aux
licenciements
parce que à un moment si on veut gagner
du pognon aux frontières gagner du
pognon aux fonds de pension donc aux
retraités
il faut qu'ils aient moins d'employés
dont il fait un deal il à 6000 euros par
emploi supprimé à partir du moment où il
n'y a plus de 1000 ya plus de morale
il n'y a plus d'enjeu humain et tout est
permis
ben pourquoi pas finalement une prime
aux licenciements c'est à dire pour
chaque salarié licencié
le président touche une prime c'est
puisqu'une bonne idée non alors vous
dites que les grands patrons gagnent
finalement 200 à 500 millions d'euros
alors qu'il ya une dizaine d'années y
gagner de 5 à 10 millions oui chaque a
eu une experte d'explosion de la
rémunération des grands patrons et la
première rentabilité et donc pour eux il
ya dix ans un patron américain gagnait
85 fois plus que la moyenne de ses
salariés aujourd'hui ian 530 fois plus
quelqu'un qui a une 300 millions de
dollars
une année qui vont en gagner encore 300
millions de dollars l'année d'après
c'est à dire plus qu'il ne faut pour une
vie entière intempérance sur 15
génération c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
qui va pas et donc c'est ce que décrit
un peu le roman c'est l'intériorité fait
la psychologie de quelqu'un qui fabrique
en permanence du manque au point de
vouloir gagner 300 millions de dollars
quand il a déjà gagné trois cents
millions eur faut dire quand même que
tous ces grands patrons ils sont quand
même sur des sièges éjectables parce
qu'à une dictature des actionnaires qui
fait que s'il n'arrive pas à faire son
lit par exemple pour faire 20% cette
année de rentabilité de l'action s'ils
font 15 ils sont virés donc c'est vrai
qu'en même temps c'est normal qu'ils se
protègent
s'ils n'arrivent pas à faire 15 % ils
ont de toute façon des clauses qui au
moment de leur départ leur assure leur
enrichissement donc
ouais tout va bien quand ça va pas
s'arranger parce que les gens sont de
plus en plus vieux il ya un vrai conflit
avec les jeunes qui triment qui
s'annonce c'est à dire que plus sûr à de
vieux retraité qui voudront avoir
vraiment des résultats par action
formidable pour leur fonds de pension
plus les jeunes vont trimer pour rien
mais s'ils vont trimer pour leurs grands
parents oui ça va lui montrer pendant un
an par an pouvaient pas que ça peut
arriver à un conflit ça c'est probable
mais quand vous devez en tant que membre
d'un fonds de pension en tant qu
actionnaire un fonds de pension choisir
entre avoir beaucoup d'argent à la fin
de l'année quitte à ce que on décolle
délocalisent des activités en inde en
afrique ou ailleurs vous fait d'une
certaine c'est à dire contre vos propres
petits enfants enfin les enfants et vos
petits enfants c'est que d'une certaine
manière vous faites un arbitrage entre
votre plaisir personnel et la situation
de vos enfants votre petit enfant doc là
il ya en effet quelque chose qui a trait
aux conflits de générations alors ce
héros le héros de votre votre roman
d'abord donc il veut être très riche et
il fait des clauses dans ces contrats
qui lui permettent de là dit il veut
très riche mais il n'arrive jamais en
juillet justement il veut être très
riche parce que à chaque fois ils
fabriquent du monde et de la frustration
et comme ils n'arrivent pas à jouir de
la vie c'est le substitut à cette villa
qui n'arrive pas à voir c'est
l'accumulation d'argent way we à ça que
brive être célèbre et rivesaltes tél
il va être célèbre je vais être non
seulement riche mais en plus célèbres et
son obsession c'est d'être l'ami de jean
marie colombani le patron du monde avoue
être très dur et journaliste parce que
vous dites que toute façon comme tout le
monde copie le premier papier qui est
sorti dans le monde
il suffit d'être bien avec le monde peu
après ça tombe ça tombe en cascade
il a une obsession qui est jean marie
colombani pour lui jean marie colombani
est une espèce de mètre étalon
de son statut social si les copains avec
jean marie colombani
ça veut dire que là il a atteint un
niveau social d'accomplissement
personnel qui est enfin celui qu'il
souhaitait donc la presse à travers le
monde la télévision il a bien compris
qu'il fait un bon client la télévision
être un bon client ça permet d'y aller
souvent en plus souvent on n'y va plus
on est plus on est célèbre et puis à le
stade ultime de l'accomplissement sert
le sexe et la drogue je suis désolé
c'est vraiment les mathématiques ce soir
donc là vos voix dont vous raconter
orgie parc
c'est ça ma vie c'est le plus grand parc
mondial de partout alors ça va de mx
c'est pas au mixer hollande alors mixeur
land tu vois là c'est juste pour se
mélanger un peu c'est juste pour se
frotter un petit peu jusqu'à gang bang
landes retirer quelle morale de tout ça
mais c'est la première fois que ça se
passe quand même la première fois que
les générations suivantes vivent moins
bien que la précédente
et si la première fois que la génération
précédente doit aider la génération
suivante le capitole
enfin nos semences et vivent ici grâce
et la mission
dallas
coc
merci d'avoir été avec tous ses fans
merci katherine pancol d'avoir été avec
nous
à bientôt
mais
hello
[Musique]
sûrement
ces cartouches
[Musique]
cartouche bonsoir alors tout le monde
parle de vous et de votre spectacle mis
en scène par kad et olivier avec la
participation exceptionnelle de marie
claude pietragalla pour une fois les
graphiques s'appelle l'absence au
théâtre de la main d'or dans le xième à
paris
vous n'avez pas peur de jouer dans le
terreau de dieudonné non non non non
c'est un théâtre comme tous les autres
et que moi je suis bien dans certaines
fois saper le gâteau alors le spectacle
raconte votre histoire sur fond de rap
et de dance en l'assurant merdé
laurenque n ya pas de kit qui va dire
magnéto ocha tu vas te dire toi magnéto
serge
oh
ce
le patron
moisés
vas-y tu vois
j'étais comme eux noyés dans la masse je
faisais comme je m'habille comme eux
thomas
comment ça va bien si on a vu quoi
penser noailles quoi quoi aussi j'ai des
bleus depuis quelques temps katusha
mise en scène de kad et olivier
alors votre vrai nom c'est karine ben
jaffar vous étonnez vous avez grandi à
montfermeil dans le 9 3 votre mère vit
en france votre père est reparti en
algérie devient 19 dizaine d'années et
vous avez attrapé très tôt le virus de
la danse en 1975 un samedi soir en
regardant la télévision
numéro un top à c'était je crois que
c'était claude françois ouais j'ai
j'ai flashé quoi il ya un espèce de choc
avec le côté paillettes
ouais je me suis dit c'est ça que je
veux faire je dansais je veux m'éclater
je faire du show business et le lundi
suivant
vous êtes au conservatoire durée ainsi
ou commencé la danse rap et au
conservatoire et puis un prof nord suis
tout de suite il m'a dit battu prendre
pour tout de suite et puis je trouvais
que des petites filles a tué avec une
coupe un peu afro à jackson five
survêtement tous pourris je me suis
accroché à la barre
voilà un seul a duré dix ans pendant dix
ans c'est extraordinaire son histoire
pendant dix ans il dit pas à ses copains
il dit pas sa mère qui va faire de la
danse classique parce qu'il a peur que
les gens se foutent de sa gueule et donc
vous descendez en disant vous avez joué
au foot et vous récupérez votre sac que
vous avez planqué dans le chai by way
dans le cagibi dans le dans le placard à
compteur comme ça hein et puis vous en
parlez pas parce que sinon je
j'avais d'abord j'avais pas envie d'en
parler que j'avais une peur de me faire
incendier par les copains de me faire
vanner de me faire flamber donc eu
l'idée c'était de ne rien dire et de
faire semblant d'être comme tout le
monde ça doit férus de football à la
mecque quoi
des entrechats sur le terrain cela je
n'avais pas sur le terrain c'est soyez
pas alors les autres évidemment quand
vous arrivez aux cours ils ont des
collants blancs ils ont des choses j'ai
essayé de tutu encore plus salée pour
les 6 ans rose les mêmes grilles et moi
je tends survêtement avec la coupe uteck
sunside et puis est venu quasiment ont
choisi ouais c'était un jeu j'étais dans
le coin du point de son petit coin et
vous avez cette phrase 100000 habilite
l'enjeu a été de transformer leurs
regards surpris en regard admiratif et
vous avez beaucoup travaillé pour ça bah
j'avais pas le choix de 72 mhz accroché
à la barre je me suis vraiment accroché
croisière je sentais les regards un
petit peu d'aidé des mers un peu étonné
je sentais que le profil type des fois
même mal à l'aise et l'idée c'était de j
étais je m'accroche et extermination
quoi alors ensuite vous étudiez au
studio sylvie vartan et puis à l'école
du mime marceau et puis après à l'opéra
de marseille est à 19 ans quand vous
êtes reçus à l'opéra de marseille vous à
vous et à votre mère vous lui dites ça
fait onze ans que je fais de la danse
classique et votre mère vous dis c'est
quoi exactement là tu es vraiment comme
toutes les mamans y perd
ils perdent ou c'est hyper protectrice
elle était fière mais sais tu fais la
danse comme tu fais la maison c'est vrai
tu bouges quoi hein
non non je suis la danse classique
qu'est ce que c'est là donc je vais
montrer des photos de danse classique
tue mais ce collant là à elle avait une
espèce de de flux mais en fait elle a
été extraordinaire puisque elle m'a dit
je suis avec toi je sais pas ce que
c'est mais vas-y et surtout tu me
téléphone tous les jours voilà ce qui
l'embêté beaucoup c'est pas vous fier en
fait c'est une garantie à marseille
parce qu'elle nous aurait pas tous les
jours à la maison maintenant c'est assez
charmant aprilia béjart et c'est là que
vous prenez ce nom de cartouches
cartouches
ça veut dire j'étais fan d'abord du
pirate 1
et puis au moment de décider de prendre
un pseudo il ya eu farid chopel à ce
moment là un farid avait du rebut nique
et il était déjà là donc j'avais décidé
de prendre un autre pseudo donc j'ai
cherché plein de farid à l'envers j'ai
pris la fin de mon nom benger fardeau
djaffar ça allait pas et puis que mon
deuil d'une cartouche ou un bout de
papier c'est bien et les gens ont dit
oui à cartouche ça marche bien henry
vous seriez appelé par touches vous
auriez été beaucoup plus rock et richard
daumas et vos parents ne devrait pas
préférer que facile de danse du ventre
ou non non non non pas acceptable je
crois que ce que ce que ma mère allait
elle est heureuse de me voir
être bien dans mes baskets m'éclater
vous avez été à l'école de mime marceau
ouais ça c'était l'enfer ouais t'es pas
faire parce que je disais rien non mais
même en aux cafétérias
gt rien tout se parlaient un stress mais
je vais vous dire un truc cartouches ça
va recommencer
on va vers une interview mime
[Musique]
alors donc sans paroles la tête de votre
père quand il a appris que vous faisais
de la danse classique votre tête quand
vous fait draguer par un mec votre tête
quand vous draguer une fille est le jour
où vous serez récompensé par un molière
votre tête de statue égyptienne immobile
la tête que vous avez fait quand vous
avez fait votre premier grand écart
et maintenant il veut pas les voir voici
schalit
donc nous nous étions en taule ensemble
impressionné je l'avais dans un film et
puis tu l'as vu dans le baiser mortel du
dragon
bah oui bonsoir ça va sentir et du savon
voilà produit par luc besson alors en
partant vous avez aussi chalvidant
landais navarro d'ondés julie lescaut
vous avez été également le bodyguard de
elton john de steven seagal de ronaldo
de balladur commentitte la paix et vous
êtes ici pour la sortie le 17 février en
dvd de la puissance à la sagesse des
arts martiaux il ya plusieurs sports ea
le le karaté le kung fu la boxe état et
le teil kendall laïque ideology dessous
et vous présentez des maîtres
internationaux qui explique à chaque
fois leur discipline qui mettent en
avant leurs disciplines et puis
et puis donc moi je suis là pour faire
le lien vu que c'est un dvd interactif
pour présenter toutes les disciplines et
voilà les eaux 50% des bénéfices sans
donner au téléthon
tout à fait ils sont ils sont reversés
au téléthon jusqu'à fin février et à
partir de début mars jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
rose-marie après c'est reparti pour pour
le pour le bon la fm association des
myopathes de france jusqu'à la fin de
l'année deux mètres de haut 110 kg 1
dans c'est quoi 110 kg ça va c'est vrai
ça va essayer de lui dire par exemple
les cheveux décolorés ça se fait plus
essayent ils étaient très bien qu il al
air d une [ __ ] va essayer lui dis un
peu comme si moi je parle pas
impressionné que mon physique et c'est
dévié par exemple c'est très simple
poste a les couilles
bon en fait qu'on ce que je vais faire
sécher
essaye d'être un bisou c'est ma chose
parce qu'il sent bien que le domine
intellectuellement essaye de lui dire
par exemple que c'est une ceinture noire
de karaoke dit il le dit non ça c'est
réservé mais tu as raison mon ma folie
tandis que l'on dit lui avec les
[ __ ] qui font le grand écart mais
moi je suis un peu tape et moi même donc
ce n'est pas un secret bien avant 18 ans
vous posiez 70 kilos pour 1 mètre 94
c'est déjà beaucoup et vous avez une
croissance trop rapide ce qui fait que
vous teniez plus sur vos genoux enfin
c'est pas que je te dis plus sur les
jeux nous disons que j'ai eu
des soucis dans le sens où j'ai grandi
beaucoup trop vite j'ai pris 10 cm 1 an
et 20 en deux mais c'était terrible
alors du coup là j'ai eu beaucoup de
problèmes articulaires et puis les
articulations donc pas ce qu'il veut à
la croissance et puis tout a été décalé
il a fallu bien sûr opéré j'ai fait donc
j'ai porté un plâtre pendant 3 à 4 mois
et puis à la finale il a fallu donc je
me mette à la musculation
ouais de là j'ai développé
un petit peu les cuisses parce qu'il
fallait j'avais perdu beaucoup j'étais
pas comme ça mais bon l'essentiel c'est
que t'as rien à perdre manière toi oui
on va dire que de là j'ai pris plus ou
moins pas plus ou moins j'ai prise
réelle mangou et la musculation au goût
de l'effort parce que j'adore j'adore la
sensation vraiment du concret et plus
petit à petit on va dire que j'ai vu le
mon corps changer j'ai vu des résultats
c'est important et puis je me suis dit
que il vaut mieux être grand et un peu
plus imposant que grands et
squelettiques ou ainsi puisqu'il en
reste
voilà alors jailli votre vrai nom c'est
didier à suleija saouler mais c'est plus
facile de s'appeler shas eli portail
yishai lit c'est une bonne question je
l'aï dit parce que charlie dire en
hébreu ça veut dire mon cadeau shay ces
cadeaux chaibi c'est l'appartenance donc
c'est mon cadeau
alors on va voir si vous êtes prêt pour
entrer dans la légende on va faire il
t'a vu légende
est ce que pour entrer dans la légende
vous êtes prêt à mourir jeune comme
bruce lee non pas du tout bon est ce que
pour entrer dans la légende vous êtes
prêts à prendre l'accent belge comme
jean claude van damme
non non non non il faut essayer pour
voir dit un truc avec l'accent belge
pour voir s'ils pouvaient peut-être avec
un peu de fritsch tétras ta gueule
ah ben c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est
pas est ce que pour rentrer dans les
jambes vous seriez prêt je me la comédie
comme une saucisse comme steven seagal
non non non pas du tout je je garde mon
style j'ai avec ses atouts chacun il ses
qualités ses défauts d'accord est ce que
pour vous les jeunes vous êtes prêt à
parodier bruce lee comme uma thurman
russie est un mythe et puis il a fait
naître quand même des millions et des
millions de pratiquants d'arts martiaux
et
et donc il ya plus qu à le respecter
ouais éternellement non vous n'allez pas
rentrée dans les jambes quoi avec mon
temps peut-être mais comptent pas par
rapport à tous et toutes ces choses là
ouais alors on va dire que chacun a son
à son destin moi je je je veux faire les
choses d'une manière
je veux rester bien sûr dans le cinéma
parce que c'est ma passion
en fait j'ai la chance de de pratiquer
depuis tout gosse le sport c'est
vraiment une chance parce que quand on
est quand on se rend compte que des gens
qui sont sur un siège dans un fauteuil
qui bouge plus ça fait plus mal qu'autre
chose c'est comme aller vite pour une
aubade quand on sait qu'il ya un
fauteuil vaut à peu près 22 1900 euros
et qu'il ya 10 10% pour la sécu qui est
seulement déduite
je me dis que ça fait très très mal
quand même parce qu'il faut les sortir
et tout ça parce que
je dirige ça fait tellement mal que j'ai
besoin vraiment d'agir avec ma petite
touche et si c'est avec mes petits
muscles que je peux faire avancer les
choses pour les myopathes
j'y vais j'y suis à fond c
chailly
de la puissance 1 s'achève des arts
martiaux
là messieurs 50% seront reversés
eto'o
schalit merci d'avoir été avec nous à
bientôt
il
et
on passe au blind test
aux platines j'accueille didier 5 heures
et
j'arrivais
didier sinclair café dancefloor donc le
mix alors vous connaissez le principe je
veux l'interprète didier
[Musique]
la ville
oui lundi soir ouais ouais
mais voilà radio ps bravo génial a été
bien fort la merci donc ça fait un point
pour l'équipe de marica tu vois que ça
se passe bien attention numéro 2
bien entendu c'est toi sarah disparaît
dès jeudi premier surnom le machin pour
homme la chine
c'est mon attention news
ces voitures
c'est détendu
eh bien vous ça va pas non il est bien
le fois seul devant halak l'épisode
veulent refaire sa caméra qu'étudie
motion a dit le chef
on aime bien quand même bon très bien
enfin ce numéro 3 enfin non
[Musique]
3 0 on savait que c'était 3 0 à 3 et
ouais
suivant
m
là l'homme et sa 3-0 et qu'est ce qu'ils
sont mais me
et maintenant là c'est pour toi
didier
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même pas content - l'autre siècle soit
human league ma biche nom que s'est
terminée la semaine à venir
je suis couché à la human l'égard de la
politique va trouver attention dj non
non non cherchez le garçon
bah
avons laissé manger
alors belle remontée de l'équipe de
maïtena brian molko laurent baffie hervé
vilard 2,3 attention car touchant la
seconde c'est en fait à tuer les
sponsors d'accord on continue didier
ménard
tu
le dos
continue didier
c'est ce jour ça se joue entre marica
ebrel molko alors c'est quoi couvrir
brian las des scandales et voilà c'est
quoi après dizier
c'est comme si vous avez du passé non
j'avais dit avant
et
oh
en plus en vue
[Musique]
le coach confirme donc là ce qui est
terrible c'est que vous étiez très très
bien partie 3 0 par les ailes
un petula clark tv tv hier soir à wil
complètement vaccinés avec ce qui serait
digne tu vois quelque chose comme ça ça
c'est qui par exemple tiens on va revoir
c'est juste pour lui joue et a que lui
qui joue
j'ai fait le playback
ouais tu savais pas qui ça ça ça
maintenant on va voir maintenant que la
ville est un petit peu remonté ce lundi
merci beaucoup mieux tu vas en chansons
la nouvelle génération idier
[Applaudissements]
au bon coin avant les loisirs anne itto
et voici la voici maintenant la version
2 fatman scoop
cya
bien on continue donc ça fait 4 4 oh là
là c'est énorme
ak oui c'est au psoas gauche
attention attention didier tomasi
innover r non je n'ai clegg
non
[Musique]
mais non on va lui faire plaisir
c'est qui ça le boulanger 30 ans mais
quand on est ça
born in the last guardian depardieu ses
positions et ça c'est ce qu'ils
regardent
l'actrice de laurent baffie meridiana
brian molko et compagnie et hervé vilard
et on est à 5 pour l'équipe de cartes
poche
bon maintenant tel est maintenant toute
façon il ya plus et qui bat c'est chacun
pour sa gueule voilà absolument
maintenant on efface tout yapi l'équipe
et il ya eu une solidarité quoi y'a plus
d'entre aide chacun pour soi et pourquoi
parce que la vie est injuste laurent
didier
[Musique]
jo
et voilà annoncé brian molko qui gagnent
le banco on passe au super banco
évidemment c'est un petit peu plus dur
attention didier d'ailleurs
ripley tue la vie avant un petit répit
mais ce car tout support cartouche il
est très très fort et plus
m
je suis obligé encore c'est ma fille qui
la dit le premier c'est à ce jour
ça se joue à san qui l'a dit avant ce
effectivement ou mac et le mcs et en
plus il n'avait guère longtemps
et ça c'est semader blé dont on nous met
la patience ça m'intéresse donc qui
marque le plus de points brian un
laurent 1
attention attention on passe au méga
banco et c'est extrêmement difficile
m
donc là effectivement brian molko à quoi
non mais là c'était tellement n'est même
pas tellement mariage excuse moi un
petit air de m6 est là c'est bien que
l'art est donc là moi je tout ce que je
vois c'est que brian molko à deux points
laurent un oui et qu'effectivement m'a
énervé s'est fait [ __ ] je suis désolé
mais
il avait dit avant il manquerait plus
qu'il marque celui là est pas encore à
point bas il serait grand vainqueur de
ce soir un laser parce qu'ils avaient
engagé un salon la wii est ce que tu es
prêt c'est l'ultra bon commune
[Musique]
m
oh
non
[Musique]
bravo bravo les mecs aux renforts que
ceux des travaux techniques non c'était
tout le monde a dit avant [ __ ] c'est
lourd mais on va attendre et on va avoir
lieu en faire gagner un temps ça regarde
par exemple regarde l amour ouais
voilà c'est pas compliqué franck alamo
absolument dans la création de la
reprise et tortueux happy together bien
entendu sympathie avait dit alors c'est
fini
pour m
et qui est
les projets sérénité chez plon sylvie
bred la femme
tu soigneur de festina grégory basso la
véritable histoire ses bulles légères
vers la fin et marica merci d'avoir été
avec nous
maïtena dans les maternelles du lundi au
vendredi à 8h55 psychologie un moment
pour soi
tous les dimanche à 13h30 ça y est on
l'album s'appelle cri du coeur il sera
en vente le 16 février
10 heures jusqu'au 20 mars à 20h et aux
pme galas les 5 et 6 juin
catherine pons quand on voit ces mois
chez albin michel brémont quo placebo
tout l'album
sleeping with ghosts l'édition et 24
février
protège moins sort le 3 mars et en le
dvd sort mais c'est l'orgueil l'avarice
2300 le 16 mars
car soutient de la main d'or du jeudi au
samedi à 20
franck jusqu'au 31 mars et au festival
rock l'onu
a toulouse le 2 avec toi couche merci au
bataclan paris volley joint chailly
dvd de la puissance d'un sagesse des
arts martiaux
ça sort le 17 février et 50% des
bénéfices sont reversés à l'afm
l'association
détente et blind test icje sinclair son
album s'appelle dancefloor le vix merci
merci didier sinclair je vous rappelle
toujours appel que reporters sans
frontières sort un album d'helmut newton
keys a quitté récemment pour la liberté
de la presse au profit de tous les
journalistes emprisonnés dans le monde
merci
[Musique]
tout
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]